netflix has been hit with four felony
indictments over the film cuties because
uh that film depicts children pubescent
girls in lewd adult activities
and um the strange thing is and i
suppose it's not strange to most of us
but one thing that's happening is that
the establishment left and many left
activists
have been and are still outright
defending this film as if it should
exist because they say it's a critique
the strange thing is you can critique
something without actually doing it
imagine someone doing drugs and saying
don't look at me i'm just critiquing
heroin that doesn't quite make sense but
where it gets interesting is that
these felony indictments come from a
grand jury meaning a district attorney
showed the film
two people and asked them if i thought
it was a crime and these people said yes
and now netflix is facing four felony
indictments so i think that's
interesting as to what the media tells
us versus what regular people think so
we're going to talk about that we've got
obviously a bunch of stories about
what's going on in ukraine but sometimes
the war talk is just we get it there's a
war and it's all everyone's talking
about but we will
the view
earlier today i think was earlier today
called for effectively called for the
arrest of tulsi gabbard and tucker
carlson for pushing russian propaganda
that's how insane everything's gotten so
we'll be talking about all of that and
we have uh two guests joining us today
first we have kelly j do you want to
introduce yourself
hi i'm kelly jay uh i am a women's
rights campaigner from the uk
right on is there any is there anything
people would have known known you from
or anything you focus on specifically uh
yeah i focus on the word woman
specifically to keep it for women
uh i got a billboard taken down in the
uk in 2018 that had the dictionary
definition of the word woman which is
removed for an adult human female who
knew uh
it got removed for hate speech
what yeah
all right
okay uh well so we have a lot to talk
about interestingly we have a couple
stories out of ukraine
where uh
one story is about a trans woman who is
not allowed to leave because a trans
woman is male and
men aren't allowed to leave the country
i i know youtube's going to hate the
language but i'm just trying to describe
it and the other story is a trans man
who put on
feminine clothing to be able to escape
the country so it's an interesting so
we'll get into all that stuff and then
obviously it'll lead us into a lot of
what's happening with ukraine but uh we
also have libby emmons hanging out hey
glad to be here i'm libby emmons i'm the
editor-in-chief of the post-millennial
glad to be back everybody right on
what's up everybody ian crossland over
here for me and crossland.net i'm
actually working on my brave browser
right now and setting up my brave search
engine if you haven't done that yet you
can flip over away from google or
duckduckgo and set up your brave search
engine it's in beta i actually use that
all the time i use brave yes do you use
the browser and the search engine yeah
good
perfect and i am also here in the corner
pushing buttons i'm wearing one of
kelly's shirts i don't know if you guys
can see it it has the dictionary
definition of the word woman which is
highly unpolitically correct so i'm
looking forward to wearing it in public
and seeing what happens
when when did daylight savings time had
was that yesterday sunday night sunday
i'm wondering if there's a lot of people
in the chat who missed that i think it
was last sunday that was uh yesterday it
was yesterday yeah yesterday yeah
people think that it's seven o'clock
someone was like why are they starting
early we're so early and i'm like it
looks like some people yeah this is the
dawn of time yeah it was yes everyone's
like
men have been confused all right
daylight savings yes
i think it's so dumb just wake up an
hour early i guess but whatever it's
brighter out and it's eight for whatever
yeah all right before we get started
everybody head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com
you can pick up virtual shield the
virtual private network to help keep
your data safe right now i think more
than ever it's obvious why we need it
with the january 6 committee just going
to these phone companies and being like
give us the private records of these
people and the phone companies are like
you got it this is why you want a vpn
it's not a perfect shield but it is a it
is a basic layer protection that will
help keep your data safe you'll get 50
50 off a lifetime discount at surfing
internetsafe.com they say virtual shield
lets you browse the web completely
anonymously so the big name isps and
service providers and other third
parties will not be able to monitor and
uh sell your internet activity and
browsing history when using their vpn
service your traffic is routed through a
secure and encrypted through a secure
encrypted servers that means that any
restrictions censorship and blocks on
your internet are bypassed you can enjoy
browsing a fast reliable and secure and
always available network it is free for
30 days available on mac windows iphone
ipad android chrome
virtual shield does all the work for you
your entire connection becomes secure
private and encrypted virtual shield
routes your internet through advanced
encrypted servers across the globe to
prevent your isp from being able to
track your internet traffic
personal family and business plans are
available family plan includes 15
devices business plan allows you to add
as many employees as you need virtual
shield completely encrypts your wi-fi
connection blocking hackers and everyone
else from accessing any of your data so
again surfing internet safe special
thanks to virtual shield for the support
they were our first sponsor going back i
think now six or seven years so rock on
virtual should we love you don't forget
go to go to timcast.com become a member
and support our work directly you'll be
keeping all of our journalists gainfully
employed and they're eternally great
grateful for it and also you'll get
access to members only podcasts from
this show we're going to have a members
only version of the show up at 11 11 or
so p.m i imagine there's a lot of topics
that are really sensitive that we're not
going to be able to talk talk about but
there's going to be a i think we'll just
put it mildly tonight's members only
show might get very um it would it would
piss off the sensors i'll put it mildly
so check out timcast.com but let's talk
about this first story about netflix
this is what i find to be absolutely
fascinating netflix takes on texas
attorneys analyzed the outlandish fight
over cuties the hollywood reporter is
basically
they're talking about a story in which
this month there was supposed to be a
hearing in texas netflix is facing a was
was to face a criminal charge for
i think it was like child lewd behavior
or something there was a a federal
ruling that overturned the statute from
texas about children and lewd activities
or lewd behavior
so the the d.a who
strangely enough as the story goes
played
played the character spider in the film
school of rock his name is lucas babin
brought the case brought the film cuties
to a grand jury and asked them if it
depicted children in
child
adult films to put it mildly and a grand
jury returned four felony indictments so
now what's happening is we're seeing
with tywin reporter story
they're bringing in these lawyers who
are like oh it's a first amendment thing
you know they're obviously critiquing
the sexualization of children and we're
now in this strange world where
when a d.a brings the film before a
bunch of regular people and says was a
crime committed they say yes
yet the establishment media the left as
you would call it is defending a film in
which they took four young girls
i don't care if you think it's their
actors or actresses or whatever actually
taught these little girls to do these
dance moves had them do it in an
extended scene that was like three
minutes long have scenes where there's
clearly adults grooming these children
and then said but it's a critique it's
fine
this is the this is the you know if i if
i can get i can broaden the the
conversation a little bit outside of
this
clearly
we live in completely different
realities with whatever the
establishment in the left is from
regular people to
i'm kind of thinking of george carlin's
obscenity push against obscenity i
understand i i'm you know morally i felt
like that movie was a little too
sexualized i think you made the example
earlier it's like
in order to explain something you don't
have to like show it necessarily like
something really vile you don't want to
like put it in front of people
that you're doing you know when when
shakespeare wrote plays all the violence
happened off stage you don't need to see
it to know what happened
it's a great point
yeah i mean those little girls actually
doing those scenes in front of a whole i
would imagine mostly male adult male
crew it's just gross i mean what were
the parents or anyone thinking well so
so i think there's one part of this
story that easily
proves they know they're doing something
wrong in the hollywood reporter they say
conservative circles have rallied behind
criticism of the movie for sexualizing
exploiting children babin's father texas
congressman brian babman u.s senator ted
cruz and a group of more than 30 house
republicans have called on the doj to
prosecute netflix this and other calls
by conservatives to investigate the
making of the movie prompted netflix to
apologize for inappropriately
sexualizing actresses in marketing
materials
the marketing materials were scenes were
clips from the movie yeah they were
pretty nasty and the issue is that it's
not a critique because they actually did
it they actually did these things with
little girls
um as kelly j was saying you know in
front of an
audience of crew
they paid them for it you know they paid
the children to do these things
um
there was a lot of incentive to do a
good job three no one pleased the people
who were
asking them to do it i brought up carlin
because he in order to show the obscene
thing that he was wanted to make more
publicly agreeable he would just do it
he would say it he would say the words
that were horrendous and at the time and
this is kind of like so the metaphor is
like the child sexuality is the dirty
words of the 70s it would be different
if it was an animation it would be
different if it was
yeah which is also disgusting and weird
it would be different if it was adults
playing children
right
that would be difficult or they could
just like the kids could have come out
on the stage and then it could it could
have showed the people's faces yeah and
then not actually put these little girls
in that situation carlin got arrested
for saying the words but he did it
anyway he was like i'm just kidding but
he was saying words he wasn't and he's
depicting the abuse of children which is
different right and even if you say
things like if you if he had
said out loud what was being done you
know what these girls were doing and
being made to do if you say it out loud
that's also different than actually
doing it so it's what makes it i think
more similar to um like a pornographic
situation
is that just like in adult films the
acts are actually performed will be
crazy is if it was about child murder
and the movie was all about showing kids
getting killed
if there wouldn't be any emotional
backlash like there was about child sex
would they be different would the
children actually be killed no it would
all be acting just like this is all
acting no no no no but it's not acting
once you're doing the actual thing right
so like i mean even if you're acting
like you're doing the thing you're
actually still doing the thing
it's yeah and it's like if those if that
was a snuff film if you're talking about
a snuff film
that would be there would be a lot of
backlash of that well i mean and
i wouldn't call it backlash i would say
like pitchforks and it would be you know
it would be illegal it would definitely
be illegal to do like i think this is
you guys see cuties i haven't seen it
no i wouldn't watch it i didn't watch it
i i see
some of the bids
yeah
so the issue for me was i
watched
enough of it to where i said i i'm not
interested in watching this film
and uh
yeah i'll put it out i did not watch the
film as if to say like i sat through the
whole thing but i watched the relevant
bits to a certain degree and was just
like this needs to be turned off it's
it's disturbing dude they got a kid that
looks like alexandria ocasio-cortez that
the main 12-year-old actor looks like a
sexualized cortez it's well insane
talk about sure but that's that's that's
like a french film yeah what a weird
coincidence yeah so cuties is the reason
that i cancelled my netflix subscription
i was like this is unacceptable sorry
i'm just not having it i don't feel like
giving money to a company that thinks
that this is tolerable
i was more angry when they pulled star
trek the original series
imagine it this way ian imagine they
made let's make a film critiquing uh
children doing drugs and we'll literally
give kids crack and film it and then be
like like a reality show
that's the issue so it's more like that
i think than what carlin was but is it
was it a reality i didn't see the movie
was it a reality show it wasn't it was
fantastic it was it was almost fake but
i mean look what do you mean like the
movie wasn't they didn't actually go
into a club and get 12 year olds dancing
there no no no audition and they
probably had to sign a contract and
their parents had to agree to this group
but it was sexual it was so they had to
whatever they were doing acting or not
it was a sexualized performance so it
doesn't really matter whether they were
acting they were still actually doing it
with their real bodies so the funny
thing is the response from a lot of
these people on the left is that the
final scene in question where the little
like 11 year old girls or whatever are
doing the sex dancing is that the
audience is disgusted by it and i'm like
but you all literally watched it too and
they actually had these little girls do
that
so what
show someone being grossed out by it and
all of a sudden you're allowed to do it
that doesn't make sense to me if you're
criticizing it you wouldn't do it right
also when we do when we have um like tv
shows or stuff like that in the u.s
usually
adults do it like
90210 which is the first thing i could
think of
all those actors were in their 20s right
and they were like
having sex and doing whatever they
weren't actually having sex but they had
like all the make-out scenes and stuff
but everyone was in their 20s the same
with like you know riverdale or any of
those shows they're all in their 20s
what about superbad i brought this up
when i was talking about this earlier
today there's a so uh christopher mintz
class i think was like 16 when they
filmed the movie and there's a scene
where he's you know he's having sex with
some some woman or whatever and
apparently his parents had to be there
and sign off on it i'm wondering
you know
this is a 16 year old we know high
school kids are doing things but is it
still does that make it better at all
because i'm actually wondering i'm
wondering yeah as you're saying that i'm
sort of i'm wondering about that as well
i mean i still thought it was messed up
realistically a 16 year old boy and 11
year old girl are worlds of different
when it comes to sexuality that's true
all right one is
going you know has gone through puberty
and is still doing it and the other
stuff is exploitative though yeah yeah
filming a 16 year old boy that's
certainly not i would never sign off on
that for my kids i had been a 16 year
old boy i would have launched at that
opportunity well it was so short but so
here's what would your parents have gone
for it yeah they they supported whatever
my choices my parents did not do that
i honestly feel like this along with you
know what the the whole florida
controversy over don't say gay i it
really does feel like it's not in the
bill right it's not but but you know
their their their perception of it or
what their critique is
you look at
super bad there's a scene where a 16
year old kid is hooking up that's in the
movie and then it's not like graphic or
anything but it's clearly a scene acted
out by this kid and they want you to be
like ah they're 16 year olds you know
you know we know high school kids are
doing stuff then you end up with shows
like big mouth which is like 12 it was a
show like 12 and 13 year olds yeah that
show's messed up it's a cartoon though
it's a card everyone's like oh but it's
nick kroll it's like famous actors
pretending to be kids and it's just
cartoons and i'm like
it's still weird do you know you guys
know the show big mom i don't know it
you've gotta watch it really right it's
yeah it's the most overly sexualized
cartoon i've ever seen children yeah i'm
not i'm not god and you're saying i have
to watch it
it's like it's just gruesome you might
get sick to your stomach and then he's
got like a little deep sex demon on his
shoulder that tells him no it's not
little it's a massive it's crazy
yeah i won't watch it i tried some sex
demons would be large they'd be like
overbearing
i'm taking over
netflix got critiqued uh criticized
critique is probably the wrong word for
it because there's an episode where it
shows two little girls walking around
naked and it shows a whole bunch of
naked women and they said no no no we're
trying to tell little girls to be okay
with their bodies that's why we're
showing it and people said look dude
it's a cartoon there were no actual
children here
then what happens you end up with movies
like cuties where it's like now you have
actual little girls doing it but oh come
on it's a critique just like and i'm
just like yo why don't you guys like
stop yeah well it's interesting too
because this stuff is coming up in books
too that are now you know available in
schools there's this whole controversy
with this book
genderqueer um by a person called maya
koabe i think i don't know how to say
her name exactly right but um
but this book has been
talked about by parents all over the u.s
um that this book has child pornography
in it and that it has like depictions of
you know all these crazy things so i
bought the book um because
i had been writing about it and i was
like i should really take a look at this
book myself and it is rather disturbing
not just for the reasons that the moms
that i know
were complaining about it but also for
this journey of this young girl who
comes to realize comes to decide that
she's not a girl at all that she has
like these other pronouns that are like
uh
they start with ease
em ear yeah that's it em ear and so the
book eventually is the story of this
person who grows up to be a comic book
artist
who's 25 has never had sex has no
interest in sex is binding um
is binding their breasts and is teaching
middle school and planning to come out
to the middle schoolers as an asexual
a eam heir and this is all like very
affirmed and it's all very you know
couched in this language of hyper
positivity
the main character in this book
hates their body
is terrified of going to the
gynecologist which if you're a woman
like you gotta show up at the
gynecologist at a certain point at least
a bunch of times in your life to make
sure that you're not dying from a whole
bunch of reproductive issues that can
kill you um
so you know this person is terrified of
that terrified of being touched all of
this stuff
and it's it's in the language of joy and
uh
spectacularness look i i can
you know understand adults who want to
live however they want to live you know
someone's over 18 and they decide they
want to
you know juggle oranges all day or like
dress up like a giant duck i'm going to
be like literally i don't care what you
do man you can go mind your own business
but it's the it's the it's the obsession
with children that i find
you know
yeah like why does your why do you need
your middle school teacher to come out
to you and tell you that they hate their
body
and
it's like a tick tock right all of these
people actually do come out to really
small children
in this fashion but there is a there is
an overwhelming surge to break the
frontier and boundaries of kids just
totally erode all safeguarding not allow
them to use words that are literal and
mean something
um and the sexualization of kids whether
it's cuties whether it's this cartoon
but it's like
it's as if you're doing something
remarkable if you're trying to enforce
this onto kids
it's so messed up it's um yeah it's
almost like we've destroyed our culture
to the point where there's no way for
children to gauge when they're adults so
we just have to decide that they're
adults from the very beginning and can
understand this stuff so kids are
learning about gender identity
before they know what sex is why uh uh
well i i don't think it needs to be
asked but to the left
you know my question is to the the to
the left in general
why they think there's an age of consent
now the issue is i honestly think the
left
is is as opposed to that idea of an age
of consent i think many of these people
are just
they're just
ignoring that issue for now
but i think if you were to actually get
these people in private and ask them
they'd probably advocate for really
really messed up stuff i think that's
correct and i think we've seen that
right i think what they're doing is
they're eroding our culture with you
know things like cuties and defending it
and i'm like could you imagine this film
being made 15 20 years ago well 15 20
years ago or 20 years ago anyway like
tip or gore would be pissed right and
she was the
she was the second lady or whatever the
vice president's wife who put the
explicit advisory lyrics on
you know my jane's addiction album we
see all those uh things on twitter have
you ever seen like maps the the the
minor protected person stuff
or that's foundation prostasia the
prostatia foundation which is all about
uh
advocating for
uh
pedophiles to be accepted in society
you have to wonder about what these
people's true goals are at the end and
then you know you have to wonder about
uh why people like
epstein kind of just disappear
why why max
elaine maxwell gets convicted but
convicted of what where where what is
what did she do i mean we're talking
about a crime that involves two people
right
where are her clients
why they all get away with it and then
it's really funny how it's just like
anybody who brings that stuff up is
clearly a conspiracy theorist and you
know they must be making things up and
i'm just like dude the netflix thing is
really really fascinating because i
don't think they're gonna be able to
walk away from this one a grand jury so
apparently the feds are like we're gonna
we're gonna have a hearing on this in
june or something or july over whether
or not you can this this stands but i
have a feeling that the d.a is going to
say to the federal judge we completely
agree with their critique yeah and and
agree you know you shouldn't sexualize
kids okay but they did it's such a shame
though don't you think with netflix
because they've really stood up for dave
chappelle
they are willing to sort of allow
i like
supposedly controversial opinions and i
i really was you know i totally backed
them for that i think that's brilliant
but
and then they do this and you're like oh
come on please i don't i don't know if
they actually back dave chappelle to a
certain extent you know the last special
that dave did was heavily focused on
trans people it's like a really it's
really weird yeah dave did a special he
mentioned uh he had jokes about trans
people he got attacked heavily for it
and it's it seemed like it consumed him
and so he ends up yeah his next special
ends up being this kind of like
it was very defensive yeah it was linear
it was nearly a ted talk to be fast yeah
no seriously yeah where he was like you
know and he was like i guess people just
don't understand the joke so i'm going
to stop doing them right they got them
what did you think of that what did you
think of the whole chappelle thing uh
well i have issues anyway because i
i think he's incredible for walking away
from all that money and uh keeping his
dignity and credibility all those years
ago uh but i'm not really a great big
fan of his humor some the way that he
talked about candice erwins
i just can't really get past that um but
yeah i think
it's bizarre that comedians ricky
gervais is the same they sort of tell a
joke and then explain the joke and like
why when have you started doing that
just tell a joke if it's funny we'll
laugh and if it's not we'll move on but
you saying oh this is a joke because
actually i'm doing a bit of wordplay and
i'm doing this and please don't cancel
me it's like no just have the
bravery you know those things have a
joke indeed yes
a story that
is a great overlap is this story from
newsweek about jk rowling and youtuber
vosh sparring over international women's
day uh mainly because one of the one of
the critiques against vosh
the more the most common ones is about
his comments on young children and
sexualization of them yes and so he is
an interesting uh character in this in
that he kind of embodies a lot of
these critiques we're talking about yeah
so this story is you may have seen it's
from it's actually from
five days ago j.k rowling called vosh a
a a a likened him to an abusive
ex-husband who used to tell me my life
would be great if only i'd comply but
you're making the same mistake he did
women like me can't be bullied out of
resistance there's a couple things i
find interesting here that we're talking
about one um i don't know if you saw
this but recently
um what's it what's her name emma watson
does her name right oh yeah yeah she she
said
i'm here for all the witches and
everyone like clapped
i don't know what that's supposed to
mean but a lot of people are assuming
she was making like a trans affirming
statement or something she looked
gutless when she said it so i think she
was
all the witches is that what she said
she said all the witches oh my gosh like
what does that mean
i'm here for all the ladies i think but
jk rowling's an interesting uh subject
in this and interestingly washes as well
because we're talking about the weird
grooming of children and stuff like that
vosh has been heavily criticized for
that jk rowling you know it's an
interesting story for those that aren't
familiar i mean this is the the gist of
the story
uh she said someone please and the
shadow minister for equality is a
dictionary in a backbone happy
international women's day and then vosh
said women be quieter and start
apologizing challenge
to which uh
she responded with that you're like a
basic abusive ex-husband he said listen
joanne you don't get to play the victim
card when you're the advocate for taking
away women's rights here trans women are
raped and killed in men's facilities and
you want to keep them there because of
your trauma quit making your feelings
other people's oppression
for this you know my attitude is like
and i said this before this is not to be
cute or
hyperbolic or facetious i believe that
vosh
is a is a men's rights activist oh 100
yeah like saying women
shut up or you know women be quiet and
start apologizing like a language like
that 10 years ago they'd call him an mra
yeah and even socialists were called
mras so this is like
this story
and the issues around jk rowling
everything's going on man i really just
want to reiterate the point there are
two different realities we know it it
includes war it includes law it includes
politics it includes culture
and this is where the two realities just
clash all the time well it's sort of
fascinating right because we have set up
an alternate reality as a as a culture
we have social media and the online
realm which is an alternate reality do
you guys remember second life where you
could like
live in a in a virtual realm and now you
have meta which is like you know second
life part two or whatever where you can
live in a virtual realm so as we are
creating this alternative reality that
we all engage in every day you know and
if you're in media you engage in it
constantly like i'm always on twitter or
whatever um and then there's real life
and when you talk to people in real life
they know fully that um men and women
are different and that biological sex is
innate and then when you talk to people
online they don't know that so it's like
this battle of
which
which realm of reality is going to which
dimension is going to win the war of
what's true
yeah um and what's interesting is when
you have concepts of transgender
ideology which also is backed by you
know concepts of transhumanism which is
the intentional evolution of humanity
with the help of technology right so you
have this you have zoltan eastvan who's
a trans humanist who ran for president a
few years ago
um
you know he didn't have a chance
obviously but there is there he was out
there
we are
grappling with this we are grappling
with the question of what is real what
is truth what is reality and uh
you know i wonder what is going to
happen it's fascinating to watch it and
as our culture moves further into the
realm of transhumanism where we uh you
know believe that our bodies and minds
are two different entities that are
at certain times apparently at war with
one another um in the in the realm of
transgender ideology anyway your body
and mind are sort of at war
what is going to happen it's a it's a
fascinating situation and also
terrifying have y'all seen them film
surrogates
no
it's uh interesting movie bruce willis
there it's a future where people have
these like pods they lay in and they
plug in and their their consciousness is
transferred to a surrogate body a robot
version of themselves
and so you see like bruce willis is
looking all like perfect you know his
hair is to the side or whatever you know
it's like combed and he can run super
fast and jump super high because it's a
robot body then he wakes up
old and disheveled and wrinkled in his
in his apartment no one goes outside
anymore because it's dangerous you gotta
send your surrogate out in your stead
in the opening
there's a guy and a woman come out of a
club and they're hooking up and then
someone is able to kill them through
their surrogate so it's like a big deal
when the police go to the woman's
apartment they're like ma'am are you
here and they find a 400-pound morbidly
obese man you know sitting like in his
chair whatever having died or whatever
and so
i think that's an interesting concept
they did that there's something
something with when people are given the
choice to project themselves what do
they want like they can on the internet
as either a cartoon animal
or
identity less anonymous
they just choose what they would what
they wish they were right and i wonder
if
one thing that drives identity crisis in
people is
living too much on the internet
yeah to living in your body you know
what i mean yeah i think we don't live
in our bodies as much as we used to for
sure you can even tell with like so many
of our trends are about trying to make
your body okay you know you've been
sitting for too long right yeah maybe
you should exercise you've been ordering
in for too long people have been
bringing you food for too long eat this
protein but so i'm wondering if um
you know you look at the metaverse
i don't know if you've seen the videos
like mark zuckerberg they are terrifying
heck but they look like me's like from
from the nintendo switch or whatever
they don't or like from the wii i guess
but they don't look like humans i'm
wondering if people will start
identifying as that and then
because that's what you see as a person
that's who you interact with i'm
wondering if a lot of what we're seeing
because the identity crisis stuff isn't
just trans it's it's sort of everybody
yeah are you familiar with other kin
kelly yeah yeah yeah people who think
they're like they think they're dragons
or there's that whole there's that whole
like refuge in colorado of a bunch of
people who think they're cats oh what
and they go there for like uh
cat people orgies and things like i'm
not kidding that sounds horrifying yeah
but yeah i think
i think all of this stuff i think it's a
transhumanist culture war
i'm hopeful i'm hopeful i think real
human connection
is actually a really powerful thing and
whilst we may trend away from it and
people may shy away from it somewhat
i don't think we can escape it i think
that's i no i can't live in a world in
which we are heading towards
not touching each other and but we're
already we're already there
the 20 year olds are having less sex
than ever before more like a for asexual
is part of the
lgbtq
alphabet soup right it's all in there
asexual is a sexual identity
uh there's less sex less people want to
have kids um there's less touching
there's less data i think that we will
get to a point though where this
like this un-personal chaos will just
reach peak and then we will just revert
back to
you know maybe if there's a massive war
right yeah maybe if there's like a maybe
if there's a reason for all of us to run
screaming into the woods
but it has to do there have been so many
the internet and video games
if if we keep living in digital spaces
then it'll only get worse could be that
our species is splitting i was watching
like evolution of humanity documentary
last night all you see the branches of
trees and then like the homo erectus and
then you've got the hominids that come
out of that and like they appeared
you'll have like like neanderthals and
homo sapiens came together but we were
different so like now we've got another
race of like computer zealots that are
like a genderless computer hominids and
then we've got other everyone else
that's still homosexual so you're saying
the next stage in human evolution is
bodyless conscious entities that exist
in digital space maybe but the problem
with that is all through history when
when a species splits they go to war
with each other and like one of the one
of the branches will end up becoming
dominant so like x-men we might see that
and if they have like brain neural
plants and they can move machines with
their minds that's going to be hard to
defeat in a war so why yeah well yeah
yeah yeah that's interesting too with
like neural link and stuff like
terminator
well sort of but imagine you know look
it's not going to be if if you're going
to
break it down towards who is most likely
to get neurolink it's going to be city
urban liberal titles sure not going to
be concerned it is it that is a
transhumanist thing the neural link and
so what happens then when you know the
people who live in cities are neural
linked so they have direct access to the
summation of human knowledge
for better or for worse and then you're
going and competing against somebody who
doesn't
like in certain areas they're going to
end up being better than you at certain
tasks there's also sort of a
i was talking to a friend of mine about
this who has cerebral palsy right and so
there's a lot of things that he can't do
and i was slamming all this stuff neural
link and um
the idea that there would be these
surrogates because we talked about that
like that you could go out as somebody
else and you're and he was like that all
would be awesome for me because i can't
do [ __ ] you know like and he was very
like if that were happening now i would
go move my random weird arm with my
neural link that i can't move now and
it'll be communism right you know why
why if you took every single human body
and put them in pods
and then plugged them into the matrix
their limitations would be defined
mathematically by the code not by their
physical bodies which is somewhat
randomized so you could be six foot five
two hundred pounds of you know 280
pounds of pure muscle in your pod in the
digital world you are a week i was
thinking that last night
i had my computer and i like blew my
nose and threw the tissue away i'm
thinking like all this stuff i just did
i picked up the thing and i blew my nose
and i took a sip and threw it like that
was all in a computer if i was in a
computer simulation i couldn't
be able to do the variety of of
calculations that i can do in this
reality there's this like limitless
potential of actions that you can take
in base reality and like what exactly we
were just saying in in the metaverse
you're bound by the code you can't you
can't go chop down the thing and take a
sip of the because it does it isn't real
it's just it's the illusion of the
system i mean depending on how
complicated how complex the system is
yeah but when you're playing in video
games online
your character like if you're playing
like world of warcraft for instance
online video game you can be stronger
than another character but everyone is
given an equal starting point and
everyone's given a relatively equal
ending point though some items are rare
and harder again you got to work harder
for the most part if all you know in in
the real world some people are better
than others extremely limiting the video
games are extremely extremely limiting i
imagine having children is like the most
adventurous thing you could ever do like
if you want to have a mind adventure i
would imagine that that's
interacting and creating a human and
then being in a relationship where you
can like
change your body at will in ways you
didn't understand that it could be
changed
maybe the easiest way to break down
what's happening is not authoritarian
versus libertarian it's not
multicultural democracy and
constitutional republic it's literally
transhumanist versus
what's the what's the word for someone
who's not a transhumanist a human
they might they'll call them ludites but
right that's the negative connotation
that's the other word
humanism no they would call them like
they would call them like humanist
versus
you're gonna go to a bank and are you
human plus or are you based human uh i'm
human plus would you like the premium
plan the premium
plug in your neural link and we'll give
you the 50 gift card
yeah because we'll i'll just have little
rfid chips in our hands
it's going to get brain hacked and that
those people are all going to be tracked
and then like a
hive mind yeah they're gonna like it
dude but they want it they won't know
they're in it they want it
they want to chop off their legs and
have like special jumpy legs i have
total control what are you talking about
legs and shutting down yeah it'll be
nuts yeah have you seen black mirror a
couple episodes yeah there's a really
good one about all this sort of
crazy you just load yourself up or every
time you walk past someone they they
sort of rate you
yeah right well because they can scan
like if you have an rfid chip now it can
be scanned
and like people can get the information
off your chip and then someone's gonna
hack it and be like they'll have a real
low rating but they'll make it look like
they have a four point eight it'll be
like you'll be like changing your report
cards mom will never know that i failed
chemistry now think about what's
happening think about what happened with
all the vaccine mandates now think about
what would happen if everyone's hooked
up to a two-way uh computer connection
to your own brain
the government's gonna say for
everyone's good you need to involve you
need to install this anti-virus software
in your neural link and everyone's going
to go okay
and it's going to literally start
sending information into your brain
right it's so dangerous there will be a
download you're not even going to know
it's downloaded it'll be yeah it'll be
like it's going to corrupt this person
will be downloaded well but that is what
elon musk's neural link is all about
that's part of it it's so that you can
you know it's like the i'm such a dork
it's like the binaries on star trek you
know they have like their whole
but it's like once everyone is linked by
these by these neural links uh there'll
be a lot more information that people
will have but there also will be no
individuality no independence no liberty
wrong wrong analogy you don't think it's
the binaries
oh well there's that too the binaries i
guess were like
the innocent version it'll be like the
borg but they're gonna because they did
have their world computer that's how it
starts yeah they're gonna think they're
individual the borg at least knew they
are part of the collective these people
are gonna think they're individuals but
they're gonna be be being controlled
kind of what's happening now with tv and
commercials and stuff or being
manipulated without realizing it well
yeah there was a recent ad there was a
recent adidas ad that was all about it
was like women in sports except it
was it was all about trans women in
sports you know really and yeah did it
show any females it should show some but
like trans women was like a big part of
it
we're gonna do like we have this
interesting segue from this conversation
into ukraine surprisingly but it you
know i guess in this day and age
with a story from a business insider how
a transgender ukrainian man escaped
russia's invasion
i painted my nails violet and wore mom's
shirt to look more girly we then have
this story from tmz
transgender woman i'm fighting two wars
in ukraine fears russians and
transphobic ukrainians
so this is interesting because in the
story about the trans woman in ukraine
because of the war they announced if you
were 16 was it 16 to 60 year old man you
could not leave the country right
legally in ukraine a trans woman is a
man
whatever your political opinion is on it
that's the view of the ukrainian
government i do think it's funny that
the left is just like totally on board
with ukraine
i get it you know the russian invasion
is a bad thing but you got like nazis
there and it's like the government is
transphobic but whatever so you have the
story where this trans woman is like you
know i'm a woman and i can't leave
because of this rule then you have this
other story about a trans man so this
person is born female
paints their nails and wears feminine
clothing to be able to escape the
country
to me it's interesting you know i'm
wondering
there have been a lot of men males who
fled ukraine as well as well as women
just like the titanic right i mean and i
understand if someone's like i don't
want to fight in a war and they want to
get out but this is like your country is
being invaded the interesting the
interesting thing to me is i understand
these are two unique individuals we're
not talking about a group here but it is
fascinating the two stories we get out
of here are about a biological male and
female a trans man and a trans woman
both trying to flee the country and not
stay and fight for it yeah i mean the
headlines interesting isn't it fighting
two wars actually they're trying to not
fight any
right
right exactly not the gender war not
anything we
we talked about um
thomas i think sounds pronounced this is
the
biological male uh trans woman who's
competing against females in college
swimming
yeah yeah you pen but there's also a
trans man so someone born female who got
top surgery and competes against isaac
isaac hennig at yale so so my issue is
it's it's i mean obviously the ukraine
thing is a situation of war life and
death so i'm like hey anybody who wants
to get out and is worried we should help
these people um when it comes to the
college swimming thing
my question to the left which they have
no answer for and they just insult me uh
is okay so if you're saying that a trans
woman is a woman and then should be
allowed to compete in the women's
division because the woman's division is
a social construct division right and
say yes okay well isaac is a man
identifying as a trans man therefore
they shouldn't be allowed and they say
but isaac's not taking testosterone
right that's the excuse so so we're
talking about bio biology or or society
they don't know well whatever suits
their argument well it all flows in one
direction like when you whether it's a
trans man or a trans woman they're both
trying to find a way to leave the
country the trans woman says but i'm a
woman you can't say i'm a man the trans
man says i'm going to paint my nails and
wear women's clothing what i don't
understand is why is the person who is
female but um
trans as a man
why do they have to do anything like if
they're a female why wouldn't they just
walk over the border so so the so i mean
if well because
if you're a female right you can have
short hair and you can i know this is
crazy but you can wear a suit you could
wear button-down shirts you could wear
men's shoes if you're a female and it
doesn't change anything about being
female i haven't heard that you can even
keep your fingernails super short yeah
and unpainted and you still are female
no no but i i think
one of the big issues in the culture war
is that you know whatever our faction is
we assume too much about the other
side's beliefs and understandings of
things
i think it's fair to say that they don't
think that a woman can have short hair
or do these things
well now if if a young girl
says i want short hair and i want to
wear blue jeans they ask the child if
the child is trans right they don't know
what they do yeah they don't they don't
say well maybe you just like short hair
it's become like if you act
this is the strange thing to me about it
maybe i should understand that if you
have a child who says a little boy says
i like dolls then all of a sudden you
have conversations about whether the
child's trans when the child doesn't
have an understanding of sexuality
because they're pre-pubescent right and
they just like stuff right and you don't
even know why they like stuff like maybe
they like dolls because they like the
color or the texture
you know or being able to tell stories
with dolls
i don't know sure stick in their trucks
you know whatever it is but we don't ask
children what it is that they like yeah
sometimes the joints of the doll are
what make the dog cool doesn't have to
do with like if it has blonde hair as a
girl i had one where you press the
button on the back and she winked at you
it was western barbie matt walsh brought
this up um after the uh the dr phil
thing he did
he was he said if you know if a little
boy or his son came to him and said
that he thought he was a girl he said
we'd ask him why and often you'll hear
him say things like i want to play with
dolls and he was like but boys can play
with dolls too sure it's funny because
hearing matt talk about stuff like that
that's like that that used to be
progressive that was the original that
was like much the feminist perspective
right if you're a woman you can dress
and behave however you want you can
dress the way men stereotypically dress
you can behave the way men
stereotypically behave you can do any of
that right you can sleep around you can
do whatever
it's fine
uh and now we've switched all that up
we have we have taken the gender
stereotypes and embedded them further
yeah and it's it seems like the modern
uh
progressive left's world view is that
there are social behaviors intrinsic to
sex
yeah i'm confident i'm just confused i'm
just i don't understand there was a
there was a case uh discussed on the bbc
and uh
a little boy lived with his mum
and she had two towels after she had a
shower for her hair and her body
and one day he said i'd like two towels
and she said you don't need two towels
so
he said but i'm a girl
and so she went to bed that night and
thought deeply about him being a girl
not that he just wanted two
damn towels
um and then he started on his road to
transition at like seven
socially transition that mess up it's
just so weird my son uses like four
towels i don't know what he did before
i come into the bathroom i'm like you
really needed all these towels
why did she say he didn't need two
towels though he has hair right
i have no idea this is her this is her
very brave journey about discovering
that her son was really a girl
and so
i think she was a good thing to say
i think the question is you know
what about this child saying that they
were a girl
is is like
confirmation of a trans identity i mean
obviously for her like right so like
what what makes you think
from saying i want two towels to saying
that you're a girl makes the leap to
their biology is wrong and they need
medication or some kind of surgical
treatment right i mean
i'm assuming that she went to the doctor
though right for me
if we assume she hasn't got
something like munchausen's by proxy
um
there is a lot of social status for
average people to gain by doing this
brave and super wonderful mother
and it is women unfortunately it's women
that that go along with this narrative
with their kids it's not so much dads
well it's sort of a feminist fascism
yeah so you know where we have taken the
ideas of feminism and we now impose them
by force
i don't i don't i don't think words uh i
think this is probably intentional but
words have almost no meaning at this
point
what is feminism that was intentional we
were actually before we went on tonight
um kelly and i were looking at the
definition of gender and gender identity
on um what like wex law i think at
cornell
and they're this they're the same
they basically have the same definition
which were gender engineering gender and
gender identity are all about like your
perceived self and your innate internal
self
which doesn't which isn't anything like
it's just absurd we've taken and we gaze
in so deeply that we think we see
something and it's not i just try to
avoid all of that social argument stuff
by just saying sex well that works out
so i'll say like
male and female instead of men and women
and then i'm just like there you go fine
whatever it still doesn't work with
canadian hate speech laws really but
we're in this really bizarre sort of
idea that our bodies are not connected
to who we are i mean i am my body
if i was if i was taller i'm sure i'd be
slightly different if i was a lot
shorter i mean i don't know if that's
possible but if i was if i was shorter
i'd be a completely different person of
course if i was a man walking around in
the world with a testosterone and b
being a man and being treated like a man
there's a there's a trans um there's not
a trans there's a transaction between me
and the society in which i live and we
both kind of find out what and who i am
it's not just up to me and it's not just
up to them
and it's bizarre that we're deciding
that gender is separate from that your
internal sense of self
is a social construct is the most stupid
idea and it doesn't make any sense you
know i was just thinking about someone
in prison maybe how because people are
adaptable and their sense of what i am
like in prison they're like what do you
what do you even think i what are you
who are you and then you beat the hell
and like when people are getting like
sexually assaulted in prison and like
over and over and over and over again by
some big guy and it's a guy and he's
like i'm not gay but i have to create a
new reality for who i am in this
situation
so they create like a new gender almost
to to exist within that without being
insane
so i understand that
the people that that's happening
to people i think it's honestly if you
zoom out i think it's happening because
like there's so many people on earth
misproportioned in cities and all these
phenophthalates in the water and and
pharmaceuticals like making people
androgynous and making people kind of
it's like shaving off conspiracy theory
i don't know it just seems logical isn't
that isn't that true though that birth
control is in public drinking water yeah
pharmaceuticals go into the toilet in
the pee when people pee them out after
they eat the prozac and then that gets
in the water supply people are all
really really messed up and it might
just be a process of the human race kind
of shedding its skin
look at that
yeah it's a that's a fact yep so we uh
we got the story from inside our birth
control pills can we add 3 million doses
of hormones to our wastewater every day
some of that estrogen may wind up in our
taps
yeah this is a story i heard about a
while back hormones from birth control
pills can travel through showers toilets
and washing machines to local wastewater
facilities
in his book troubled water activist seth
siegel writes that birth control pills
add more than 10 million doses of
synthetic estrogen to u.s wastewater
every day from there the hormones could
get discharged into rivers and lakes
that serve as sources of drinking water
only only a tiny portion of the estrogen
in wastewater makes its way to u.s taps
but siegel still thinks we should remove
it
so i think maybe it's a bit exaggerated
as if you're like turning the tap water
on and there's gonna be birth control in
it it looks like it could be an issue we
all also aren't we having a fertility
crisis
what is that all about like there's we
just aren't having enough kids does it
mean that people aren't trying enough or
that it's people there's a lot of trying
and there's a lot of not having children
like because they're light too light
what there's that there's like being
older
um and then there's uh
being older is one of the things but
there's also been issues of fertility
like there's i don't have enough
information food supply high fructose
corn syrup aspartame we have birth
control you have how many uh oxycodone
how many of these pharmaceuticals that
are legal are getting pissed into the
water supply that's kind of crazy what
are your guys's thoughts on birth
control
i have lots of thoughts on birth control
you can hear him yes
uh
so i went on birth control when i was
16.
my doctor said that i had polycystic
ovarian syndrome and that uh i should go
on birth control to regulate my cycle
so i did i did go on birth control um
and then i was on it for a very long
time i was on it until i was 32
32 33
something like that and then i went off
it because i wanted to have a child and
i had for that whole period of time i
thought i was depressed i thought i was
maladjusted
i thought it was awkward i thought i
like was socially weird i thought all of
these things about it myself that i was
like morose miserable and then i went
off birth control and it literally felt
like a dam broke
in my entire body and in my brain also
where it was like suddenly i could see
everything in color
and i just felt like an entirely
different person
and i suddenly really was more outgoing
i liked being around people more i
wasn't really depressed i mean i was
still miserable because i'm still me but
i wasn't like depressed about everything
um it was shocking it was so shocking
that i had to go back on it within a
month and i had to like wait a little
bit to go off
yeah wow well there's and then it turned
out that i didn't have polycystic
ovarian syndrome i wasn't infertile
there was no reason for me to be on the
pill that entire time and i had suffered
from like for a while i was on this pill
where if i went into the sun i would
pass out oh
jesus christ right and i was in l.a i
was like this is not working there's
there's two i do not recommend birth
control there's two big issues one is
the feminist view that birth control has
empowered women because now they're free
to function you know without fear of
pregnancy which could potentially hold
them back or whatever but then there's
also the fact that our society has
mass-medicated young women that's
correct and i'm wondering have we
tracked for the psychological impacts of
mass-medicating young women well i've
gone through like i've done a little
study of other
you know essentially upper-middle class
girls um
in my age group
all of us were put on birth control when
we were about 16.
like every one of us and i was like did
you have a reason well my doctor said my
periods were weird and the reason that
they say stuff they give you a reason so
that your insurance covers it
right
so my insurance covered it for the
entire time the doctor
wanted you on it yeah the doctors want
16 year old upper middle class girls in
the u.s on birth control so that they
don't have teen pregnancies
i mean
i guess teen pregnancy is a bad thing
but like you know that's yes it's it it
now i sound crazy but in looking at like
all of the women i know of that age oh
it's very like this keeps this has
happened to all of you birth control
makes it harder to have kids and they're
peeing it into the water supply and it's
harder for people to have kids
have you heard of the um mice utopia
utopia experience all the time yes it's
just
well when they give mice a lovely place
to live
and enough bedding and enough food and
enough everything and eventually the
mice go a bit crazy and turn on each
other and stop having sex and oh that's
like america
well you just wonder
we do talk about the the utopia
experiment quite a bit i think he did it
the the guy did it with mice and rats
like he did one in the other and um
a finite amount of space but unlimited
food and water and then the rent just to
see what they do and they would have
what's called behavioral sink where they
would their their
rat society would break down and they
would start eating each other and
killing each other i was thinking about
that because we're effectively running a
chicken utopia experiment
and i'm half kidding but we launched a
youtube show called chicken city which
is just livestreaming the chickens where
they have a large amount of space
unlimited food and water and
like we have no intention of like
harvesting the chickens i'm i'm
wondering if we'll see something break
down or if chickens will just you know
not be like they're different you know
different species or whatever it's
different from you know mammals do they
have a limited space
they do yeah it's big though
but uh uh the the the rats in the mice
had limited space but it was a decent
amount what was interesting is that in
those experiments they would all cluster
in one bunch in one area and not utilize
the full space they were given
so
i just wonder if we lack purpose
you know i i just look at you know if my
kids ever talk about millionaires
uh sort of kardashian-style millionaires
and i'm like billionaires they're
well
billionaires
millionaires billionaires just a lot
more than me but i sort of look at them
and i think what's the purpose of their
day
like what are they striving for and do
we as human beings need something to
strive for because if you've got nothing
to to aim for to go for to move forward
for
then don't you just stay still and then
just become unhappy yes so i had a
friend who became a millionaire when he
was like 16.
and he said that he had an existential
crisis right because all of a sudden
it's not just the fact that he was rich
and could buy anything he wanted it was
that all of a sudden he was like the
lord of everyone the way people treated
him he no longer had uh
like teachers who would tell him he was
wrong all of a sudden it was like hey
let me get that for you oh you're so
smart wow look what you've done and he
said that you know it happens to all of
these guys in tech who become
millionaires rather quickly because they
like write a code write a program then
overnight it sells and that now they're
worth three million bucks and they're
sitting at this massive bank account
thinking what do i do now like you wrote
the code you wrote the program you
solved the problem and now you're rich
but they never they never did this work
because they were trying to get money
they were trying to accomplish something
and they become listless depressed they
sleep all day he told me that eventually
most of them they'll go like six months
to a year and finally
normalize and then you know their happy
happiness stabilizes and they try and
find their next mission or whatever but
i think that that it you know hearing
that story
and then think about the fact that i
think
most people in the united states today
are living like kings
may be why we're dealing with this
collapse this behavioral sync i i
definitely think the us is dealing with
behavioral sync like much like the rate
utopia i think
you know you've got i've seen it with
like occupy wall street
all of these people protesting this is
you know now almost 11 years ago or 10
years ago
when i went to when i was in brazil and
many who listen to this show probably
heard me tell the story but forgive me
because i haven't told it to kelly
when i went to brazil
i was in the favelas and i met you know
the favelas are shantytowns they fall
apart in the rain and uh some one of the
the woman asked me in portuguese a
question and it was translated why are
the rich people protesting in the united
states
and i said
it's a very good question but i said i
don't understand they're not and then
she asked and he was like oh she's she's
asking about like occupy wall street and
i was like oh those were like college
kids kids with debt city people living
in cities and she left just like
the americans are all rich
her question was like i think it was
probably mistranslated she wasn't saying
why are specifically the american rich
people protesting she was saying
something like why would americans who
are rich protest about this stuff
and it's really interesting because i'm
like hey you're preaching to the choir
man i i'm like if you've got air
conditioning in a refrigerator
you're living better than rockefeller
did 100 years ago so we're all basically
taken care of what do we do with our
lives
create problems you know complain about
stuff i sometimes think you get to the
top of uh maslow's hierarchy of needs
and then it inverts yeah and then we're
just heading for
just doomed so kim kardashian came under
a lot of fire that i didn't think she
deserved because recently she said
something along the lines of you need to
work hard and everyone's like oh you're
rich you don't know what it's like but
she keeps herself busy didn't she go to
law school like she didn't just like she
didn't go to law school but she has been
reading law right doing this other
different way to get a law degree she
has a company right and she's doing all
this different stuff i completely agree
like you should be staying busy no
matter how much money you make and
especially if you get richer it's like
the matrix you know and in the first
matrix agent smith tells morpheus he's
like the first world we designed was
perfect but the human mind rejected it
because it craves conflict and struggle
it's like yeah without it people become
almost deranged
well also we we have a lack of so i'm
what you call a gold star atheist i've
never believed in god um but i think the
organized religion and the
mutual purpose of people and collective
purpose
of heading towards an afterlife of
actually trying to do good
uh for something that you can never
touch
i think that also has has left us
wanting and i think the where we've
looked is within our narcissistic little
bodies yeah that's right we have turned
in and we we worship the self where we
used to worship god and now we do we do
worship the self and we have uh removed
the soul we've extricated the soul and
replaced it with gender
ah it's so beautiful
i do think it's interesting that the
culture war has made a lot of people
like theist
or whatever i've got a theology degree
so i'm a
vested interest in you're an atheist
with a theology degree
yeah i mean i love this that sounds
right i want to hear everything a
theologist yeah tell me about it a
theologist
that's wonderful no
i think that makes sense if you're going
to be an atheist to know what you're
talking about well i thought i'd find
some so for a start i thought university
because
i'm an idiot was going to be like kids
from fame which is probably way too old
a reference for any of you i liked um i
liked the show so you just sit in an
individual chair and you'd all sort of
discuss these really meaty topics it
wasn't quite like that but
i i just thought there may be universal
truths
and if i study theology i may find
universal truths and then i may examine
my own belief system but that didn't
actually happen
however i do think the universal truth
of human beings absolutely needing
something above and beyond themselves
is something that now we're finding out
to our peril
yeah do you think above and beyond like
a partner
i think anything that that makes you put
yourself a little bit lost
um whether that be family community
that's you know whilst we've lost our
organized religions uh in the uk
probably more than in the us
but and it's no mistake that in poor
countries they still are very religious
so whilst we've lost our religions we've
also lost our sort of touch touch your
parents because they're just next door
kind of culture we don't have
communities
we've all moved away from each other
many people live tens of miles if not
hundreds or thousands of miles away from
their parents
and i just don't i just think these real
things that you can reach out and touch
are things that we desperately need
doesn't it doesn't it feel almost like
it's intentional i mean think about it
the idea that you turn 18 move out move
away from your parents separate from
your family go off to college you go to
college what happens you get a bunch of
strangers indoctrinating in these
institutionalized learning facilities it
just seems like a lot of things that
have happened over the past 60 70 years
have effectively orchestrated the
downfall of the family and our society
i'm not saying it is that's really
interesting i'm saying it's just like
you've got people who heavily advocate
for separating yourself from your
community from your family i just think
that's interesting when i when i was
looking at college and stuff my mom
wanted me to go to college very far away
we lived in philadelphia
i had only lived with my mom for two
years i didn't know her that well i
didn't really grow up with her um
and she was like you should go to
california you should go somewhere far
away for college and i was like
i'll go to new york like i'll go you
know but i'm not how far do you really
want me to go like i still i barely know
you i don't have a home anywhere you
know i was totally rootless
and so i landed in new york and it's
still a situation where i have i feel
like i have no roots anywhere i feel
like i have like
when i look around you guys know i've
had this struggle of should i stay
should i go in new york and it's like i
don't know where i'd go
if there was a place where i could go
home if it was like oh i could just go
back home i would do that but i don't
have
i don't have any like
place that is the home that i know
other than new york city it's weird i
had that growing up we would go my dad's
mom my grandma we lived like eight
blocks away so we would go there every
four days a week three days a week two
days a week whatever awesome and then i
moved in college i left the state and i
now i haven't seen my parents i see them
once every two years or something it
doesn't feel right i was just talking to
my mom yesterday about that just
it's only six hour drive but like it
doesn't have that feeling of we're gonna
pop over to my grandma's house on the
weekend let's let's let's let's we can
sort of bring up the the don't say gay
lie
the hoax from the democrats
the bill in florida's true intent was to
make sure parents are informed about
what's happening with their kids
the left lied and claimed it was don't
say gay i know we've mentioned it
several times but i think this is you
know relevant to what we're talking
about if if they're using these
manipulations to try and stop
transparency
one of the things in the bill is that
teachers can't discourage children from
talking to their parents that's because
one of the things these teachers are
doing is telling the kids not to talk to
their parents it just seems like there's
a lot of external pressures on people to
sever themselves from community family
religion etc
ultimately you you add in the the
transhumanist factor or the neural link
and the metaverse and what you end up
with is
in order it feels like in order for
there to be like a metaverse you would
need these things beforehand yeah in
order to get your hands on on kids you
need to break up the family and the
strongest connection
uh pardon me for saying is mothers and
children
and
surrogacy is a massive thing that
totally separates the idea that
mothers carry children and have children
and raise and nurture infants
and so all of it is there's not much
that we're doing that actually
reinforces the family and i know the
family in america has got the weird
connotations of family traditional like
homophobic
if you mention family values all of a
sudden you're saying something anti-gay
um
but it's
it's just really interesting if i was a
predator if i was a nasty predator
predatory pedophile i would absolutely
love the segregation of of children from
families and and mothers from children
and disempowering mothers and there's no
greater way to disempower mothers and
actually rob women of all of their
rights and power and vocabulary of all
of their rights as a mother yeah to even
call yourself a mother yeah it's it's
shockingly horrifying to see how this is
going on and then you have school
districts like in florida there's a
couple of cases um i was talking to a
woman january littlejohn the other day
who was suing her school district um
because they started their her daughter
on the road to gender transition and
didn't tell the family so another family
in florida
where
they didn't know that their child was
exploring gender identity at school
until the child tried to kill herself
in the bathroom at the school and then
it turned out that they were keeping
they were having like secret gender
identity meetings and the idea
right that was florida which
precipitated the parental rights bill
right where they clearly need it
you know so you have situation where
educators and administrators think that
it's their job to help children keep
secrets from their parents because all
parents are going to be abusers and they
even said in that one case in florida
well the family is catholic so they're
automatically going to be abusive and
non-understanding and the father was
like uh what
our religion teaches us to love our
children
i kind of just feel like
you know whether it's intentional or not
over the past several decades there's
been a major push for the precursor of
transhumanism i think it's for sure yeah
intentional i find that if we're divided
into subsets of classes in this species
that we have we have the the elite and
the plebeians which is everyone else and
it's really a class of elite whatever
you wanna call them are they they are
family tight they are knit units where
they like the children run the business
that the dad ran and they're always in
contact and they're flying on their jets
to see each other and their their kids
know their parents and then you got
everybody else man and they're just
letting the wild animals graze right now
i just i just kind of realized something
you know i used to make the joke that
the future is going to be everybody with
shaved heads wearing jumpsuits
or giant you know cones over their
bodies so that no one can tell because
if you you know uh um like
harrison yeah uh bergeron is that what
it's called yeah
harrison bergeron
uh and then i just realized why that's
wrong
because people are going to plug
themselves into the neural linked
metaverse where you are just a gray blob
and everyone will then just be the same
generic avatar i don't think they would
they will be the same avatar i think
you'll need to pick your starter oh to
start yeah everyone's gonna be the same
for sure so it'll be the blank slate
ideology and then you have to grind for
your for your outfits and your stuff
here's the interesting thing about it
though
if you take every single human being
and erase their minds or if you do this
you take one million babies
and you put them in the metaverse where
they all start off as genderless you
know jumpsuit wearing little humans and
they grow and develop and then you know
around the time that they're 10 or
whatever it's like now choose your
gender and they can just pick i'll tell
you this you would find a massive
correlation between biological sex and
internal digital world gender
so they can so so if you take a kid and
raise them
in you know metaverse
i i would be willing to bet there's like
a 98 chance that kid would be like i'm a
boy or i'm a girl
they would decide it or they would be it
what i'm saying is if you ask if you
take a child a baby and put them in the
metaverse right where they never
experience the real world and they have
no gender
then at 12 years old they go to school
you ask them which gender would you
choose they would likely choose their
biological sex the one they actually are
right yeah so even in the metaverse
they'd also really need to stretch out
they'd be like this feels uncomfortable
well their brain is neural linked they
wouldn't they wouldn't know that they're
trapped in a pod so they wouldn't even
know that they have a body no
and so i mean they probably would i
think if we enter this transhumanist
reality where everyone is a blank slate
and everyone's born this way
you're gonna it's gonna like you're
gonna have a million babies they're
gonna they're gonna grow up and then
you're gonna see a 98 correlation with
biological sex of the physical world
body and the chosen gender in the
metaverse is it overhead so well i was
just going to say look
because i
i'm far too hopeful to think this is the
future for human beings but also
even if you're right there's only going
to be a certain number of people that
can afford to join them the you don't
think the metaverse everybody's got a
cell phone
it's only it's only a matter of time
it'll start with the rich people but
then give it 10 years and it's gonna be
a 20 metaverse pass and what about the
people that are religious and are family
connected in countries like india
see uh i actually
i'm working on a tv show
yeah so i can't say too much but it
basically explores the idea that there
are a lot of people who will not take
the neural link and a lot of people who
want it
and what ian mentioned is there's kind
of divergence happening within human
evolution right now where you're going
to have what you said homocyberneticist
or whatever something like that over
homo cybernetic versus homo sapien and
you're gonna have a lot of people who
are like this is the real world we love
our family we believe in god it's
interesting because we're now facing the
real prospect of a divergence between
the human species
by choice almost by ideology so
did you read uh em foresters the machine
stops
so basically that's what happens in the
in that it's like a little novella
um and i think he wrote it in like 1914
or something ridiculous like that and
basically there's people in pods and all
of their information comes to them
through this view screen and there's a
machine that they can ask to bring them
food and whatever it is that they need
but this one guy reaches out to his mom
and his the way that he has a mother is
that the machine set her up with this
guy and they had a child and then the
child was taken to like a nursery pod
where it was raised but anyway he
reaches out to his mom and he's like i
would really like to breathe some clean
air they live underground in this thing
oh yeah yeah i saw a movie that was
basically this maybe yeah it was
but it's interesting because in the book
there is this one guy who's like no i'm
not doing this
he was raised in that in that
environment and he comes to it on his
own
that he doesn't want to live like this
and he eventually makes it to the
surface of the earth where he dies from
the poison air but
he tries
he tries i mean it is kind of a happy
ending because he's like i made it
i see the sun
i see you know well so uh for everybody
listening maybe you can you guys the
audience is always really good at
helping me out with this there's a show
it might be electric dream was it
electric dreams is that what the show
was called
but uh i watch all these different
sci-fi anthology shows it's a kid who
lives in this you know pod where he
plays video games all day and he
interacts with interacts with his mom
over text chat and they just play
platform video games and food is
automatic and then one day his pot
breaks
he has no choice but to go outside where
he thinks the air is toxic but it's not
and then he goes to his mom and he
knocks on the door and she's freaking
out like what is going on why is there a
person here it sounds very similar to
what you were describing but it's you
know yeah i mean i it sounds similar i
think it's i think it's a similar theme
in in literature
i wonder if you're gonna have like
humans on mars that are neural linked
humans on mars that aren't humans on
earth that are neuralink humans on earth
that aren't and you'll have like four
different species
and then they'll all go to war and one
of them will become the predominant
species
would you do it would you neurolink in
yeah you would do it yeah
some people are saying it was electric
driving i've been clearing my mind as
practicing meditation where you have no
thought for like ow i can have like no
thought for an hour and the metaverse
can be really important because they're
gonna be trying to read your thoughts
so you gotta like the end of
ghostbusters were like don't think of
anything he thinks of the marshmallow
man right he sure doesn't think of
anything you need a clear thought or
they're gonna be controlling them uh-huh
so do you think then in this in this
happy
future that we're all looking at that
those in
maybe authoritarian religious countries
will they be less likely
to hook up
i don't know about that it's a great way
to control the population
yeah so they might just say we'll create
our own isolated introverse
where everyone can you know
it depends on whether you think the
people who run
do you think the people who lead iran
are actually religious or they want
power and control well i think they're
both because then if if it's just about
power control they'll say whatever they
have to and absolutely would adopt a
metaverse-like system
if they're actually religious they
probably would resist
depends on how religious or how they
interpret their religion oh yeah there
will be religions in the metaverse and
stuff where it's like it becomes a
religion you're the funniest the
funniest they'll worship like you know
it would be a huge golden calf it'd just
be hilarious if we're actually in it
right now and
what i think will happen is some people
will start we'll start metaversing
government military and then they'll see
it's so powerful to be able to control
the machines with your thoughts that
even the most religious
zealous will start doing it because it's
either that or die like don't fall
behind on the technology it's a weapon
it can be used as a weapon for sure if
we were in it right now i don't think my
children would be so rude
but if you know what i mean you might
not know you know
you just you know maybe maybe uh we're
the remnants of a post-apocalyptic
civilization that destroyed the planet
and purposefully chose to put ourselves
in a matrix so that we can live oh
that's such a road to hell
a whole
process is
yeah that's a that's a spiral into i do
i don't think we are i i just only
because i have no evidence i don't think
we're not i just don't think we are no i
agree with that but i do think
it really does feel like that's the
direction we're going in you've got
people who
jump from one cause to another you see
what elon musk tweeted yeah i support
current things the npc meme holding
ukrainian flag with all the other flags
around it
and i'm like that's that's a great point
i'm wondering what what it is that has
created this large group of millions of
people
who are mindless drones
it makes me wonder
what if
well i'll put it this way i think those
people are absolutely going to neural
link and go into the the metaverse and
just live
march and lockstep i also wonder if if
it's true that we are living in some
kind of simulation
maybe we're the people who are actually
in the pods and they actually are npcs
you know oh the whole npc thing i
watched that show free guy the other day
that movie that's my son he was like we
should watch this
uh because i was telling him that i
thought um i was telling him that i
thought the whole npc concept was really
wild and uh and i was like what if
there's npcs in real life and he was
like
yeah i've been thinking about that we
should watch this movie and i'm like
you're 11.
you came up with this already yeah yeah
i think people can like go into mpc mode
and then snap back out of it and all of
a sudden they have sentience again
they're like oh my gosh what have i done
sometimes i'll even wake up and be like
wow what was i doing yesterday i was in
like a a weird fog yesterday and today i
don't know i had this weird thing during
covid where like it took me a little
while to realize that this was going on
but it you know we were like locked down
and you couldn't go anywhere and
everything was closed and i started to
like just not want to move i just didn't
want to move at all and then i realized
like oh you have this weird idea that if
you just stop moving
this whole thing will be over sooner oh
we have a correction kyle billing says
the movie i was referring to was 2149
the aftermath and i remember now that's
that's going to write that down yeah
that's it sounds basically like what you
talked about yeah was poisonous and he
was in a pot or whatever 2149 the
aftermath yeah you know you know movie's
also cool totally totally irrelevant is
time trap
i don't know that that movie's great
cool name yeah you think people are in
such a state of panic right now that
they're just kind of like head down wait
for this all to end wait for the whole
war and iraq to end wait for the coven
to end wait for all the pain
all the things i'm afraid of yeah wait
for the alien invasion that hasn't been
false flagged on us yet to end well we
really want things to end
like as a culture it seems like
really some people no i don't want
things to end either but like i feel
like our culture is really gearing up
for just being like and that's it we
burned ourselves out that's it enough
gravity gravity hurts let's end it was
it i think sheamus came up with the joke
we were talking about what the future
would be like and he was like wouldn't
it be funny if it's like 200 years in
the future and everything's just the
same and some guy like gets in a time
machine and goes to the future and he
comes out and everything looks normal
like it was when he left and he's like
he asked someone what year it was and
they're like oh it's 22 22 and he's like
but everything's the same and they're
like that was it like that was that was
all our ideas we ran out that was it
nothing else after that we kind of just
you know just
there's a bunch more mcdonald's but you
know other than that nothing real
beyond the kiosk right it's like a mic
judge movie
for sure they've talked about the end of
the world for the millennials since the
beginning of humanity someone's out
there like it's all coming to an end
this is it constantly obsessed with the
end there's this play i think it's
called american dream maybe it's not but
it's uh by this playwright len jenkin
who's this
new york playwright and at the end of
this sort of wild romp
all of these characters just start
saying i don't care about philosophy
just tell me how it ends
i don't care about philosophy i gotta i
gotta manage i'm at the point where i'm
like
i feel like we've reached this
a certain number of seasons of humanity
to where they're doing reruns
you know kind of sucks yeah it's just a
repeat and then it's just like okay
it's like it's like watching i saw the
batman
like this past weekend they call it the
batman that's like what the movie is
called the batman but the batman is like
a common thing yeah it's been around
like that that phrase has been around
for a long time
uh yeah there's like cartoons there's a
cartoon called the batman there's comics
of the batman but uh uh
he wouldn't have any superpowers it
would be batman's because he's just rich
actually his superpower is defined as
peak human because he's trained on the
mountaintops and he's master of like
ninjutsu and he's also rich i would just
really go with the once we get the rich
part i'd be okay yeah but but i i i i
digress
that was a movie where i was you know it
starts off like pretty good and then
slowly gets worse but never ends it just
doesn't stop it's like we've caught the
bad guy and i'm like well it's finally
over and there's an act four and i'm
like okay and then introduce a whole
bunch of random plot elements and i'm
like okay at this point and i feel like
that was a great that movie was a great
way to understand life in the past
decade
oh you think it's over and then it just
keeps going yeah yeah
but no no but but but more and more
absurd yeah like you know we went from
we've got a pandemic
with then we got a pandemic star to get
this let's let's recount the past couple
of years a pandemic starts all right
everyone's like we're shutting down the
president who's donald trump by the way
gets on tv and says we're going to be
banning travel with europe and we're and
i'm sitting there with my friends and
we're like whoa it's getting serious and
then two months later the biggest riots
we've seen in five decades billions of
dollars in damage 30 plus dead and i'm
like
is it a pandemic happening and then
we're like
back to the pandemic and then i'm like
okay that didn't end now we're now then
intermittent in all of that is like
escalation of civil war people being
killed in the streets and it's like man
the more we see this stuff and more it
feels like the country's going to
collapse and then all of a sudden world
war three starts
right it's just like okay it really
feels like someone you know and you have
the new president just go go ahead i'm
sorry oh i know the president's joe
biden now
it's like we thought it was funny that
donald trump was the president because
he's like a tv reality star and now we
have joe biden who's who is
essentially a a mr magoo yeah like he is
this is
he also he sits up there he hardly says
he like looks at you with his little
slinty eyes and then he whispers you
know kind of yells it's not gonna be
world war three we're not sending troops
into ukraine have you guys seen the
south park episode where it turns out
earth is a reality show okay and the
aliens are just like we we're we're done
with the show so we're gonna blow the
earth up it's like it's you know 3 000
seasons and we're just done that's a fun
thing in sci-fi where the earth is
actually just totally irrelevant and
they're going to pave it over for a
highway like in hitchhikers and stuff
yeah what do you think is going to be
the next thing then when
normal
people get peaked into understanding
that they're being massively lied to
so
i i don't i don't know if that'll happen
neural nets happening
see i i so because of what i do and i
defend women's rights then i'm used to
the media peddling what i call lies uh
about really important
what are what are
factually alive and and i'm i'm kind of
used to that i'm used to our politicians
going along with uh telling absolute
silly lies about biological sex and what
words mean
but then we had the pandemic in which
that sort of really
propelled more lies and narratives and
really obvious overt kind of dishonest
narratives and now we've got the war in
ukraine which
because of all these
these lies i think people are finding it
really difficult to believe anything
that's being told by the mainstream
media uh and so where where the hell
next well on thursday i don't know if
you saw this the white house invited uh
30 tick tock stars
[Laughter]
to
to give them the propagandist lines
about the war in ukraine is that like
when they peddled the hobby
oh my goodness yeah so they you know
what what could be next what could be
next i think actually we have a lot of
stuff going on with uh
voting rights i wonder if that could be
part of it like the
there's like oh i don't know who's gonna
get into all that
well that's a mess i don't think that's
big enough like yeah you know kovid was
huge and engulfed everyone black lives
matter was huge it engulfed everyone now
world war three or whatever that'll
engulf everyone yeah well that will be
the third thing right that was my first
thought was aliens but i think it's too
obvious now i think it's too obvious
like that's just not going to be the
plot point because we don't think you're
talking plasma it's just obvious
yeah but not not
it feels like
you know
we live in a reality where someone is
trying to keep people entertained you
know and it's just like okay regular
human human civilization wasn't working
the elite are trying to keep the plebs
entertained or or
it's you know in 2016 the large hadron
collider fired up for the first time is
that what happened right before trump
got elected that was wild now we're just
in this crazy multiverse of madness
doctor strange has you know because
oh my goodness like dolly the sheep in
the yeah okay that that didn't go well
well i think there's like 10 different
bidens there's all just different kinds
of
different teeth probably the difference
going to keep ramping up right
probably the war is going to keep
ramping up the ukraine thing
i think i think i think we are headed
towards hot war between nato and russia
for sure yeah i think that that's that's
what we're looking at well so let me let
me give you guys a direct reference i
don't know if actually i'm pretty sure i
pulled it up
but uh maybe we can send the tick tocks
here we go yeah so this is just a
general update from daily mail it's not
going to be world war iii this is all a
bluff democrats and republicans ramp up
demands to biden to send polish migtone
and fighter jets to ukraine because
putin is escalating every day we also
have estonia the first nato country
formally through parliament calling for
a no-fly zone over ukraine every day
we're inching closer and closer to some
reason the u.s or nato has to be
involved in this and now we're getting
these stories on march 11th abc news
reported that russia was moving in with
biochem suits
why would they say that because they
don't just come out outright and say
yeah russia fired a biological weapon
they say remember last week when we saw
the russians wearing those biosuits this
is why
and now already nato uh some u.s
official has said it's effectively you
know a red line you know it's crossing
the line it's a red line for nato
bladder vladimir putin uses chemical
weapons well biden said that last week
he said uh he was asked by reporters
when he gave his little speech on friday
i think it was friday um about what if
putin uses biochemical weapons and biden
said there would be a severe price but
you also have the white house saying
that
a biochemical weapons attack from russia
would be a false flag they also talk
about that already yeah they're talking
about all kinds of stuff it's very hard
to
i mean i cover the news every day
we don't cover a lot of like what's
going on on the ground in ukraine at
post-millennial um
we're not foreign policy experts so we
don't cover that um we cover what's
going on in the u.s about it we cover
what's going on in canada about it but
like we're reading all of this stuff
every day we're trying to figure out
what's going on trying to understand it
and it gets more and more confusing all
the time it's like it's hard to know
what's going on we don't speak the
language it's very clear that you have
two sides there that are very well
versed in how to create propaganda wars
and they're doing it and we don't know
what's what it's all lies man but both
both parties every party to this whether
it's china whether it's russia the us
has a reason to lie
and it's just impossible to know what's
going on they
you've got these people on twitter
you've got these people in media even
people on fox news you know are are
it feels like the the personalities on
fox news are trying to remain as close
to the populist american message of we
don't like war as possible while still
crop dusting vladimir putin is is
crossing that line and something needs
to be done
but i think fox news knows their
audience would be like no war like you
know we're not going to play that game
but fox news is one of the outlets that
keeps sort of talking about how there
should be a new no-fly zone no that's
that's what i mean it's like you know
what i was watching the five and i was
watching jesse waters and brett bear
jesse waters is like out there being
smug like hey we should have a no-fly
zone that's jessie me that's jessie yeah
i don't like that
no for sure but but it does feel like
you know even greg gutfeld's you know
somewhat like i don't know what's going
on or what they're saying you turn on
like msnbc and rachel maddow is just
like do as the cult says i mean she's
not really on tv anymore but you get
that point i mean i discussed before we
came on that a guy on the bbc
uh stood and gave a piece to camera with
dead russian soldiers by his feet i mean
we're just in really nasty realms of
dehumanizing soldiers which i'm i'm
guessing didn't have much of a say in
whether or not russia
went into ukraine i don't i don't it's
remarkable to me how we keep hearing
this narrative that russia's losing
but then like when you actually look at
the details it's like a russian russia's
expanding you know like the media keeps
showing these small stories of victories
for ukraine
you know there's one video going viral
it's like russian convoy ambushed and
one tank gets hit and then you see all
those little stories but then the big
picture is
russia gains more ground russia takes
over a city i was in south korea a
couple years ago and um forgive me my
south korean family and friends uh i
went to this museum about a great south
korean general and it was it was funny
to me because it was like this was a
great naval leader who led you know
korea because it was it was like you
know ancient time battles so is all of
korea in in great war against japan or
something and i noticed something
interesting it was like in the first
battle a great you know 500 ships
confronted each other and then it was
like you go to the next historical slide
and it's like the great general leading
50 ships against the 300 what a decisive
victory and you go to the next one and
it's like his 12 ships led a decisive
victory against the you know the 300 or
whatever and i'm like okay so so hold on
like you're omitting the nine out of 10
times he lost and only showing me the
one out of 10 times he won
it's you know that's kind of what it
feels like is happening here with
ukraine right they show all these little
victories but the bigger picture is
russia is slow rolling and moving in and
taking over but what's the what's the
aim with those lies is it too is it to
make putin really angry that we're
talking about him being a loser i think
demoralize the russian troops so that
they fight worse maybe but i don't think
they're watching this stuff i think it's
more so to convince the american people
that
we can and will win yeah that does that
and then when there's a chemical defense
they can be like oh no look guys you
know we're winning but we got to end it
now because of what russia just did and
then all of a sudden you know russia is
winning then all of a sudden nato comes
in
flattens russia
i can't just think nato so you think
nato is going to just go in
what would they do
nato has 30 000 troops right now in
norway doing war games and 50 warships
moved into the region which is it's it's
the baltic sea it borders russia and
it's kind of like
is that a coincidence
you know they're they want to cancel
this m this icbm test right to
de-escalate things but then send 30 000
troops for a war game you know with 50
warships
i don't think they're up there for war
games i think they needed a reason to
send all those troops and get them ready
and just leave them there
yeah yeah because russia's been amassing
troops we know that right we know that
that's for a long time i was in a cab
actually recently with a friend of mine
um and the it was an uber and the uber
driver was like really we were like hey
how you doing and he was like uh i
actually just got word today that i'm
shipping out what in a couple days i put
in for my retirement in august and now
instead they're shipping me to germany
wow
yeah geez
to germany yeah interesting
i'm really curious what you guys think
of trevor noah coming out and saying
basically if trump were in charge this
would not be happening and he thinks
that biden probably wishes he could
bring trump in as president wild card
did he wait trevor noah said that yeah
he sure did it was pretty amazing we
covered that
yeah bill maher said something similar
yeah yeah well trump said to i think uh
sean hannity the other night that he
said something to putin that made putin
clear that he should not invade ukraine
it was probably something like i'm a
crazy man and i might just nokia he said
he would nuke moscow right
so this is the craziest thing because i
think it's insane and i it's one of the
things that worries me about trump but
if it works i guess the official
reporting was that new york post ran a
story saying trump reportedly told she
and putin he told putin if you go into
ukraine i will hit moscow he told she if
you go to taiwan i will hit beijing
right and both leaders were like shocked
but hold on trump then came out and
bragged i told him i would nuke moscow
and he knew i meant it and i'm like he's
like he believed it maybe like five
percent but that's all you need yeah
the thing too though is like the the
benefit of having trump as president
like uh he was essentially an anti-war
president the benefit of having him as
president was that he was so
unpredictable and crazy that no one knew
what he was going to do he was like the
homeless guy on a corner with a knife
and crazy crack guys
you know so america was like this crazy
unpredictable
nation with nukes run by well no it's
like someone handed him an ar right now
he has a grenade in one hand and the pin
is over i think he was a predictable man
i think he was a predictable
blood-shouldered kind of bullish bloke i
think you knew exactly what he was going
to do
what a crazy thing well i think i think
he'd i think he'd
out well i can't i'm trying not to swear
he'd um
if it was a urinating contest
he would always be the
guy to win yeah so i think that's
correct i've i think americans should
have felt safer in his hands than ever
in biden's i felt safer with a crazy man
at the helm than somebody who's
imminently reasonable well a crazy guy
that works
sleepy he kind of created like a crazy
person
but and it worked in cases like with
putin thought maybe he would hit moscow
with a nuke but the american people
believed it they bought into it as well
so they thought he was crazy half of
them thought he was really crazy i feel
like turned out he was one of the most
stable presidents militarily i feel like
trump was the kind of guy to where you
could you could brag about doing
something that's kind of like
amoral or
he did no no no not trump i'm saying if
you said something like
trump could never beat me in a pissing
contest trump would be like when i take
a leak i spray it so far
so far so far everybody knows it
everybody knows i can i can write my
name in cursive like
i throw a ball faster than trump no i
throw the best balls the furthest balls
i throw them i throw my balls no but
only no no but only weird things like if
if you said you know i'm a pro bowler
and i could beat trump at bowling he'd
probably like well he's a great bowler
he's very good everyone respects him but
it was like it was weird things he would
lie about where you're like why is he so
adamant about like
that being the thing that's a reliable
that's a reliable guy right because you
know that he's gonna say
you know that he's gonna say that when
when people challenge him so someone
like putin
or china when they're sort of coming up
and saying no we're gonna we're gonna be
the world superpower he's like no way
i'm the super his superpower there ever
never wore the earth that 5 thing is
actually a really great point because
everybody knows that joe biden's got a
zero percent chance of launching any
nukes or taking any hard military action
he's not gonna do his thing and
everybody probably says you know even
putin and she would be like trump
probably won't do it and then their
advisors go probably and it's like
they're like biden's asleep he's never
going to do anything well he's not even
away anything
no he's a useless daughtering old man
he'll he'll you know he'll he'll yell
come on man to putin right come on man
and then maybe he'll whisper and like
sniff some little girl's hair yeah
he could yeah he's reliable in sniffing
women he's great at that so we have we
have chicken city which is our new live
stream where it's just the chickens
doing their thing and you know chickens
are animals so they do animal behaviors
but people calling
whatever you know roberto the rooster is
getting feisty people saying you know
roberto giving the old biden sniff to
the girl
a good old biden sniff and i'm like
that's that's one way to put it it knows
better it's funny because
it's a rather family-friendly show it's
just chickens and we make jokes and i
threw blueberries to them and stuff like
that but the comments are hilarious when
people like make jokes about chickens
and whenever you're gonna be eating
people on our social media
they'd fight for it oh i thought they
didn't those the young ones they don't
even know the little ones were confused
they were like they didn't like the
blueberries one of the people on our
social media team beth base she's a
reporter of ours she was in um ottawa
covering the the truckers and everything
she's terrific every time biden does a
sniffy thing she's like i'm getting this
clip just wait he's sniffing people
again he's sniffing the girls again it's
wonderful
this is our reporter john
his beat is bite and sniffing little
girls
and he's like yeah basically i just
watch all of his presentations and i
just pull the clips of him sniffing
women is he getting nutrition from
people when he does that because i know
when you smell something you get
particles of the thing go into your body
when you're smelling grosser and grosser
like when the bathroom is thinking can't
help it he's he sustains himself i
require nutrients yeah he's a he's a
smelly smell too you smell them
he needs some energy
yeah he's he smells
he latches on and all right i mean
that's gross because a good smell will
wake you up and that's really gross if
that's what he's doing that's nasty
let's go to super chats if you have not
already smash that like button subscribe
to the channel share the show take the
url post wherever you want if you really
do want to help out go to tipcast.com
we're going to have a members only show
coming up around 11 or so p.m we record
and then we publish it live
we publish it recorded at alumnus opm so
check it out and uh support the show at
10ks.com but let's read some here uh
super chats we got
aussie troll tretler says hello there
from chicken city you know i think
chicken city is our fastest growing uh
new show we got 10 11 300 subscribers in
one week reliable cash what one week
absolutely
all right let's see we got
silver bear says hello tim and crew i
sent my resume and portfolio to pitches
at tim cast i wasn't sure where else to
send it i love writing i want to try
doing it for a living we will look out
for it right now i'll tell you this guys
we're looking for
i don't know how to describe it we we we
need people who skate
and want to film
vlog stuff every day because
we we essentially need like an executive
producer for the vlog there's a couple
there's a bunch of ideas we have we want
it to be
fun with cool activities like we
launched the race cars over the garage
roof but we also want to do just like
gags with the crew so like we did the
thing where sheamus tortured people
pretended to so just fun stuff like that
but we need someone whose job it is to
basically focus on that so if you're
interested yeah if you could do lighting
and sound design as well that'd be huge
lighting and sound design yeah if we
could yeah i think if we if it looks
like cinema quality no i don't know
it'll get like magnitude more followers
that would be at the that would have to
be a different person
maybe
i'm talking about someone who's like a
charismatic personality and writer not a
production person yeah i'd be down to
have a good time but you know we'll take
it all so you know it's good to have a
good person yeah
is everything we can hire 10 people if
they're like we're going to put together
a show and have a good time but uh you
know ultimately we got so much stuff
going on here we just need someone who
wants to organize it we've got the air
bag launch thing we built the new patio
we're building new skate ramps we've got
ferdamastan and we got chickens and
we're gonna get goats so we just need
someone whose job it is is to like wrap
those ideas up and so you know put into
the vlog
do jokes and things like that
all right let's see
memotype says schuon had did a great
video about cuties she does a giant
breakdown of just how messed up it all
is she watched it so you don't have to
yeah you know here's the challenge right
you know how are you going to criticize
something you haven't seen and i'm like
well the issue is i've seen the trailers
and i've seen relevant clips
from you know critique and it's like
maybe i didn't see the scene where the
little girl talks to her mom about
making cookies
but i don't want to watch the movie and
watch it i like i wouldn't want to watch
the three-minute dance routine but it is
a challenge it is
because like i guess she watch it so i
don't have to you know is it still on
there is cutie's still on netflix i'm
pretty sure it is yeah so yeah yeah
yeah someone recko so we have two
chickens with no names because they were
adopted and someone wanted us to name
name name them at least one of them chew
on egg
oh that's really cute so we did yeah and
i guess the other one is hensaki because
i like that too because uh
it's like it's like a goldish like almo
it's like a it's like a it's a light
brownish like a burnt it's almost red
it's not quite but there's someone there
like hensaki and i was like that's a
really good one yeah you know
someone else that hadn't shapiro yeah i
like that too but i'm like no but we
would need a little rooster you know
what i mean yeah yeah that would have to
be a rooster a little black rooster
yeah
yeah we have one bossy little blacker
with like you know little tufts yeah
little tufted feathers that would be
cute
the mad machina says ian carlin did it
the seven words because he believed
censorship of those words was wrong your
logic and this analogy would mean the
creators believed this behavior should
be acceptable yeah i think they did
that's why they did it it's like a
social statement
of like look look in the darkness look
at the darkness but like looking at
something that's horrific so that you
can say hey i saw it isn't necessarily
good for you
michael mccarthy says wow is that kelly
j on tim pool well done i think this
might finally be the sign that i really
am in a simulation this is a great part
of the simulation though
well then definitely check out our
members only segment coming up at 11 p.m
this will be a lot of fun
all right
leguma the guy on i'm probably always
pronouncing that wrong says dear kelly
posey i admire your courage in the face
of the irrational crusading mob of woke
progressive fanatics on both sides of
the ocean we need far more people like
you i know you'll never give up your
fight be well from florida oh thanks
there you go
all right
darune albane says tim the released maps
for the russian strikes and lab
locations the maps are distorted
impossible to line up interesting
did you guys see the view called for the
arrest of tulsi and tucker carlson
yes
yeah they actually called for the
department of justice
to do it um just like the department of
justice is going to investigate parents
for being upset about mass mandates in
schools and they said people used to get
arrested for this kind of stuff the doj
needs to investigate this it's like it's
called mccarthyism yeah yeah you call it
whatever right well done
it's just
you know people are like we went from
civil war to world war three and i'm
like no we didn't we went from civil war
and
you know added in world war three yeah
it's just
layering it on top
it's like the seven layer dip we just
all need some chips
says hey tim this is concerning student
loans in australia we have something
called the hecs system where you have
your taxpayer-backed student loans you
can't default on with no interest what
stops americans from having this
we do inaptitude don't we have we do
have federal student loans yeah but they
have interest rates
yeah they do have interest rates yeah
he's saying they don't oh because my my
thing is i don't think we should just
forgive everyone's student loan debt but
we should eliminate the interest rates
so it's like pay back what you borrowed
and you know maybe with inflation or
something so it's like
you got to pay back the money you
borrowed you know what i mean i think
you probably shouldn't be allowed to get
federal student loans for degrees in
gender identity yes i think we should
not give out student loans at all
it's like if you want to go to college
get a job save up money two years later
you know go to college or maybe the
college would pay for it but that the
problem with your thing is then only
rich people would go to college which
was what the student loan program was
trying to fix anyway and all it did was
made everyone's lives worse and it made
college way more expensive right it
didn't solve anything yeah because now
all these schools have giant endowments
but but you could also work your way
through college people do that that used
to be a thing as well when like a state
school was twelve thousand dollars a
year you could do that yep now you can't
but if you link it to in fact if you
link it to inflation by now well maybe
by next year it'll be about 400 percent
yeah wow you pay back so much and so
much of what universities are our
administrative departments i mean it's
so peculiar like in the uk you could you
could do a degree in golf
in golf yeah what
yeah all right folklore mythology is
always interesting right all right we
got mike hillier says tim you are wrong
at what a mra is you are repeating msm
narrative vosh is acting like a feminist
talk to karen straw or is it strong
strong about mras and then we have
another one saying tim please stop
calling vosh and mra then we have zaring
saying fosh is not an mra no no my
friends you all don't understand
you're looking at the phrase mra as
though it's a proper noun i'm referring
to vosh as the
non-proper noun he is an advocate he is
advocating for the rights of men i
didn't say all rights i didn't say he
was in line with your proper noun view
of the uh acronym mra if a human being
says that they're going to go online and
advocate for the rights of men they're a
right men's rights advocate or activist
you know there's not one there's not one
group of you know the feminists have a
bunch of different branches mra's have a
bunch of different branches he's a
leftist mra he's definitely not a
feminist of any stripe including the
many terrible feminists that walk the
earth yeah
all right the wrong writer says playing
world of warcraft while watching this
scary also have a look at norman dodd on
tax exempt foundations very eye opening
discussion
world of warcraft was scary man i was
addicted to it like 2006 for like a good
month month or two i would do nothing
but wake up play
and i always tell people south park did
that episode where they gained all that
weight and got really fat from playing
warcraft that's not true
you you you become extremely
malnourished oh because you just don't
eat it's called a bio when you're rating
with your friends and it's like a bio
meaning you got to eat drink or go to
the bathroom typically it's a bathroom
thing but people would be like no
it's like hey we're going to go you know
we're going to go raid you know whatever
and then people are like i got to take a
break man i got to get some food or
something and be like oh come on dude
are you kidding we're like we want to
start we got we got to wait for you we
got 40 people and you'd be like oh okay
or whatever so i think i dropped like 20
pounds and i was like super thin because
you you'll drink water and all i was
doing was ordering a calzone so what did
you say the world of water is it world
this is like when i was in middle school
and i saw the karen carpenter
documentary and it talked about how she
was anorexic and like she lost all this
weight and i was like that's a killer
idea that's a great idea right i should
try that killer idea yeah
i ended up so hungry it was like half a
day
all right we got caltox reaper says tim
and ian you both need to watch the anime
ghost in the shell standalone complex it
covers a lot of what is being talked
about
good sir i have seen it i've seen the
movie and i know absolutely about ghost
nichelle uh
yeah it's great the laughing man thinks
fantastic i love the the
graphic it's a guy he basically can hack
people's brains so they can see what he
wants them to see and so when they try
and look at him on cameras and the
surveillance footage he hacks the system
so you only see this um salinger quote i
thought what i would do is i would
pretend i was one of those deaf mutes
just like spinning around a smiley face
so they're like they ask people like
what do you look like it's like i can't
remember
so when your brains are cyberized or in
the network
powerful people or hackers are going to
decide what you can think or remember
that's the future man i think they'll
call it
cyber dized
like hybridized yeah like hybrid but
with cyberized maybe i don't know yep
cyber eyes all right caitlyn says i was
a tomboy as a kid in the 80s and very
feminine now i'm so thankful my parents
didn't just think i really wanted to be
a boy girl me too
same
i mean i'll tell you something right now
that's probably offensive to a bunch of
people
the uh the first 1080 done on a
skateboard was done by i think a 12 year
old boy yeah there's no 12 year old girl
who
is is also you know hitting the first
1080 i mean it's a massive spin and so
i've brought this up to people
because there's a lot of people who
argue like oh puberty is the defining
point at which a male gains the
advantage in sports and i'm like then
why are there like 10 and 12 year old
boys competing at the at the national
level in skateboarding but no girls i
want to just shout out all you girls out
there but from a guy's perspective women
are the coolest thing on earth so please
cherish it it's amazing
i think i think that's a lot very true
for like women as well though to be
honest not like not like equally you
know because men are just like obviously
obsessed with women but the the gag the
joke people always say is on the cover
of a men's magazine is it a man or a
woman it's a woman and the cover of a
woman's magazine is a man or woman it's
a woman oh yeah the woman yeah
but that's because men don't look as
good in women's clothes and those
magazines are about selling food
it's interesting you talk about the
puberty thing because when advocates in
the uk
uh to try and stop women's sports being
invaded by men
they will talk about puberty well
actually the advantages that men have
over women is is not just puberty it's
it's bone density it's muscle fiber it's
it's all these it's cardiovascular
system
it's muscle memory even of remembering
how strong you were before a little bit
of testosterone suppressant which never
suppresses the testosterone to a point
it's the same as a woman it's impossible
to suppress uh prenatal testosterone
when you're already born the other thing
so that is muscle fiber and bone density
and all that stuff though the average of
women's testosterone that women
naturally have in their bodies i think
is like uh the highest is like 2.4 i
think it's very low like nano mules or
whatever per liter and for the ioc
they're regulation for biological males
who want to compete in women's sports is
that your testosterone has to be 10
nanomules per liter which is
still multitudes and multitudes higher
than what the highest uh average women's
and testosterone
would be if a woman had that level of
testosterone she'd be accused of doping
and yes oh yeah she'd have a beard yeah
at least yeah a lot of stuff so we got
tara tara says low fertility is a result
of poor diet eating low protein diets
low animal fats and high vegetable and
seed oils completely ruins your hormones
i'll mention this we talked a little bit
of to uh um ryan long and danny polish
chuck about nad you guys familiar with
that yeah something i think joe rogan
talks about it quite a bit uh
nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide and uh
i've been getting that but part of that
means i get my my um
i get like basically a physical every
time they check my blood pressure since
i started doing a higher protein diet
and a lower sugar diet my health has
like massively improved massively higher
protein less sugar yeah i mean i think
it's fairly obvious right like everybody
says like cut the carbs and eat better
protein so i've been eating more
i've been eating way more protein
instead of instead of a snack being
sugar-based my snacks are protein-based
that was the big change for one i snack
a lot less now which is probably why i
lost weight
when i do snack we have we have bacon we
have little individually wrapped bacons
you just rip them open i mostly just eat
fruit when i snack high sugar yeah yeah
it's delicious and
liver intensive too apples yeah apples
are hurting my liver
yeah probably fine well i i'm not a
nutritionist i don't take my advice but
i was reading about how fructose you
know fruit sugar has to be processed in
the liver so it's
minus the fiber if you do just apple
juice it's going to go right to your
liver and then convert into sugar if you
eat it with the fiber which is no i just
eat i eat actual because i think it's
some fruit
i gave up i gave up meat for lent
interesting yeah
so what do you get your protein from
i've been eating a lot of fish that's
meat
well
you gave up like red meat or something i
gave up like like yeah not fish i gave
up not fish
well that works yeah i mean fish is
actually way better for you yeah so so
my son like i've i've been making all of
this like
shrimp dishes i'm learning to cook
chinese fried shrimp spectacular wow
there's a bunch of salmon and crab cakes
in my freezer right now this is
interesting vic says my girlfriend has
been off birth control for a year and
she feels like a different person she's
happier better appetite more sexual less
emotional they're turning the frogs gay
well i don't know about birth control
going to frogs
that was a pesticide wasn't it atrazine
yeah and i think later on they said that
they were wrong
or like it was it wasn't making them gay
well hermaphroditic
but the whole study said that they
weren't sure it was atrazine in the
first place
it was a hypothesis or something yeah
but yeah that was uh
a pesticide leaking into groundwater was
uh mutating the endocrine systems of
frogs yeah we didn't really touch on
pesticides herbicides fungicides getting
into the food supply oh you know what we
got we we went and bought silky chickens
those little cute ones yeah they look
like llamas they're so cute and the the
woman who sold them to us also gave uh
she sold us some honey that she found in
an abandoned house oh that's that's
weird
yeah i was super excited it's the best
i've ever tasted did you end up like
tripping your face off
honey's antimicrobial so it's like you
could put it on your wounds to clean it
uh so long as it's done by a proper bee
keeper it's probably fine now do you
trust the beekeeper
because what beekeeper it was found in
an abandoned house you don't know
anything about it the ladies
so she also she also has like legit farm
honey but she said i found this one in
abandoned house if you want you know you
can buy it too and i was like yeah well
actually i wasn't paying attention it
was everyone else who heard it and i was
like i'll just take it all and then i
was tasting it they're like oh that's
the one from the abandoned house and i
was like tastes great
so what they say is if the bees are an
abandoned house then the older parts of
the of the honeycomb are going to have
like mold and garbage on it but the
newer parts are probably clean and safe
and honey is antimicrobial so oh she
didn't find a jar of honey
okay yeah that's different and then i'm
like picturing jar
have you guys ever eaten the psychedelic
honey
which one is that it's like the
himalayans will climb the mountain and
they'll go get the honey and they'll eat
it strip their balls off no no it's not
manuka honey why is it uh i'm looking
into it gray another toxin is maybe the
chemical they call it mad honey there
was this crazy thing that happened in
brooklyn where all of these are
legal that's awesome these bees like got
into
some sort of
industrial facility and that ended up in
all the honey and all the honey was like
weird red color yeah no it was uh it was
a candy factory it was like a candy
factory the waste runoff yeah bees were
drinking the sugar
and so they made red candy honey where
do you get the trippy honey though
what's the deal where do you find it
well i know the mountains of the
himalayas
they'll like climb long distances to get
to it i don't know though i have never
heard of this mad honey before i'm
looking into it interesting
eddie jones says i'm 21 years old and
you're helping me learn about a lot of
things i was blind of as a noob in the
world thanks for the solid info and the
sources to back it all thanks for the
20s ian chicken city is life
dude thank you so much man i if i could
have been 21 years old and had access to
a show like this that i could interact
with i would have loved this so thank
you for putting me in perspective like
that
all right josh froman says hey tim ohio
just passed constitutional carry what
are your thoughts man indiana's gonna
pass constitutional carry alabama just
signed constitutional carry i think it
was constitutional care right in alabama
yeah was it what does that mean you can
just carry a weapon you can carry your
gun yeah and there's no no permits
whatever you can you just get to have it
yeah you're you're totally pro that oh
yes yeah yeah absolutely in west
virginia you can just pick up a gun and
walk around outside and
like just have it no one cares yeah yeah
it's like you'll see a guy with a with a
with a gun in his hip and you're just
like how many states have that versus
how many don't growing i mean now i
think it's like 15 or 16 maybe
same yeah what's the argument for it
that we have the second amendment yeah
the constitution
i mean i mean the fact that it's getting
past now oh yeah like
what why so why are they doing it uh
the constitution
the second amendment the right to keep
in bear arms shall not be infringed yet
throughout most of history we didn't
actually uphold our own constitutional
rights right okay and so in the 80s even
it was difficult to get concealed carry
permits like so they were like oh no no
if you want to have a gun you better
show everybody and people are like the
constitution is clear right
so
recently i think it's because uh i i
think the populist libertarian wave has
been winning very much in the united
states over the past decade and so now
we're seeing states basically say
the law on guns is the constitution of
course you still have the feds the
federal government bans a ton of weapons
and it's absurd there's nothing you can
do about it but in texas for instance
they've
they passed a law i'm pretty sure saying
that if you make and use a suppressor in
texas the feds can't do anything like
it's the tech the state allows it
because you can't
the feds are only in charge if you cross
state lines but the feds are still
arguing
you know it's illegal you can't do it
part of it too is that biden is so gun
control crazy he has all of these ideas
about preventing people from having guns
and he was recently
in new york talking to mayor adams after
two police officers were murdered by a
career criminal who had a
who shot them with his gun um yeah the
um actually new york just launched their
new uh uh criminal division it's
actually the nypd has actually deployed
a bunch of criminals oh yeah okay yeah
the the anti-gun unit yeah yeah it's
like common sense in new york city so
new york city is in my opinion in
violation of the constitution because
they make it impossible to get a gun new
york city is in violation of the
constitution all over the place that's
just yeah it's like in several very key
places consistently and always
um but i guess people who live there
tolerate it so but they created a new
anti-gun unit these are cops who
basically go out to take away to arrest
people who are you know uh
constitutionally carrying weapons
because statutorily in the state in the
city they don't let you do it i think
that's wrong
i think if you want to make an argument
about whether or not you should be
allowed to have guns you got to change
constitution first so i got a list of
the open carry
uh number it's from the wikipedia open
carry it's better to load open carry is
different from constitutional carry
open carry means that you're allowed to
carry your gun so long as other people
can see it constitutional carry means
you can conceal it if you want to you
don't need a permit oh yeah so if you're
in a state
that doesn't have that and they require
you to get a permit and the cop finds
you of a gun you get in trouble
the moment they enact they sign into law
constitutional carry you can take your
gun put it in your waistband cover it up
and walk outside and so i think we have
23 states that are constitutional 23
yeah wow wow
according to wikipedia
that's fantastic glad to hear it
a well-armed population is a polite and
hard to oppress population and then
three more states that have a limited
form of permit-less concealed carry
illinois new mexico and washington
yeah i'm wary of anyone who wants to
strip power away from the people to give
to themselves and when the argument
about gun control is almost always that
the government should have the right to
right now
agents of the government can have select
fire rifles it means full auto or you
know burst or or uh semi-auto and they
say the regular people can't politicians
can have guns
right so celebrities can have bodyguards
who are armed and
the way it works in new york and new
jersey and maryland is basically if
you're wealthy and famous enough you can
have a gun
so they were they say you have to give a
legitimate reason why you need the gun
and if you say like for my safety or my
constitutional rights they kick you out
but if you say i'm rich and famous
they'll say we got you don't worry about
it in new york there's like you have to
have an interview
yeah to explain why you want the gun and
you can't just be like i just want it
because i want it it's not like not part
of the i was told jam the easiest way i
was told new york ultimately just like
won't won't give it to you
but in new jersey maryland and new york
the most likely way to actually get one
is to show deposit slips for cash in
access of five thousand dollars oh
that's interesting because then the
argument is i carry large sums of cash
cash for my job doing deposits and i
need to be able to defend myself because
people who find out will will rob what
if you just carry large sums of cash so
you can have a receipt so you can buy a
gun
well i don't think the cops are going to
look into your business they're not
going to check it out if you just take
it out and put it back in
when it comes to constitutional carry
all the states are pretty much uniform
except for california is all fragmented
all over california you have different
rules and all over california is not a
constitutional carry state california is
a you go to jail for having a gun
statement they have a may issue
concealed permit in a lot of areas in
california
would there be a correlation between
uh states who don't have constitutional
carry with other sort of
infringements of the constitution so
california for example i would say it
was anti-constitutional to put men in in
women's prisons
um which they of course do
yeah but i think so does washington well
guidance before the defense of it right
yes biden is pro putting men and women's
prisons as is the unelected governor of
new york city yes it's a potential 14th
amendment argument but that's it and it
doesn't clearly define what the
violation is so that's a harder question
to be right so i probably don't really
understand your constitution
i'm just wondering if there is a
correlation between uh not carrying not
having a constitutional carry and other
things that may be like free speech
so the first cover is freedom of speech
second is guns third is to be free from
the government quartering soldiers in
your home or providing your home as you
know uh
providing your home to uh soldiers the
fourth is an unreasonable search and
seizure but uh the fourteenth is
equality under the law
so you see a lot of arguments about the
14th amendment and so there's
interesting supreme court rulings i
believe what you're describing would be
a constitutional violation of the 14th
because
the way we've we as the united states
have decided equality can work is that
so long as there is uh
you can separate groups so long as they
have equal of something so it's really
funny because like you can't when it
comes to race but you can when it comes
to gender don't ask me why i'm on a
supreme court justice but it used to be
that you could have a white and a black
bathroom so long as both groups got a
bathroom
we ended that because now it's like
separate but equal was wrong now you
can't you can't do that but under the
exact same law the 1964 civil rights act
you can do that for men and women i
think this is what's ultimately going to
poke a hole
and and shatter gender gender
segregation which ultimately means males
and females will share all the same
spaces no matter what in the future
because the argument is
uh if the argument back in the day was
we don't if there's two different
bathrooms that both work the same way
then we're allowed to have race
differentiated bathrooms because it's
equal right
we said no to that okay well we do that
now for men and women so now we're
starting to see the left argue
okay well then how can you have gender
separate but equal nope there should be
one bathroom for everybody but this is
happening in new york where instead of
doing a men's room in a women's room
they're doing five individual bathrooms
with doors you just lock and so now
they're just all genderless single
stalls are they those weird doors that
you have over here that we don't have in
the uk which leave
which lit no no no no no no these are
these are these are right the way down
to the floor this this would be like
walking into a broom closet like you
walk into an actual room and you would
be walking into your own wc right but
you'll see it with a sink
on the seat yes
that's an issue yep all that stuff
um
but that's that's one of the things
we're starting to see from it is instead
of doing a men's room in women's room
with like you know urinals they just
they'll just make four individual rooms
the romans would all sit in a big room
together
you ever look at roman bathrooms have
you been to a sports bar toilet toilet
toilet toilet and they're
i don't know if they had they might have
wooden dividers i don't know i don't
know they don't mate what doesn't they
just ain't too much meat
but i don't know if they have men and
women together right were they let's
let's let's listen genders did they have
the room at the bathroom
eating while they poop let's uh grab one
more super check so we're gonna do this
member segment we have uh colton raider
says what is your thoughts on donald
trump going on a podcast and youtube
removing it within 24 hours over five
million views that was the kneel boys
full send podcast and the issue is
you've got to be really savvy on
youtube's rules to be able to pull off a
show like this so my friends you may
notice that many of your favorite
creators often get strikes and
we don't
we've gotten one warning from alex jones
when he was on the show and i think it
was bs and i think it's proof that
youtube enforces their rules arbitrarily
but there's also many things that we're
cognizant of
and we we we dance through the land mine
field there are a lot of people that
either are unwilling to or just don't
know
how youtube has aligned their landmines
everywhere and so you'll see people who
like the elk boys talk to trump trump
said things and they were like okay oh
youtube gets them or we talked with um
kim iverson
the hills rising i think it was rising
they got suspended from youtube because
they aired a clip of donald trump
speaking on an interview and trump said
something that youtube's interested that
was it and because because youtube has a
very specific rule for how you can
address certain conversations that is to
say
if
or i should say when
we get donald trump on the show
we will not be taken down
maybe because youtube's rule enforcement
is arbitrary
but
i know
youtube's rules well enough to where i
think we could allow donald trump his
space to make his points and we could
say what needs to be said to make sure
it doesn't get booted off the internet
that would be cool if you had trump on
the show i mean we've talked with uh
some of his people it's just kind of
like
i don't know
you know if trump came on the show it'd
be like we'd have to go to florida well
it'd be big yeah very bigly i would
definitely do it it would be fantastic
and um you know we'll reach out to some
of the people we've had a bunch of
people with bannon and peter department
stuff so i really like peter navarro man
that guy he's cool dude yeah i think it
would be great to sit down with trump
for a couple hours um
but i you know what we were told is like
he'd probably do a half an hour maybe
you got to come down and i was like okay
well we'll figure it out when we figure
it out so maybe we'll we'll reach out
and see if we can you know sit down with
donald trump and talk to him i don't
think it would get taken down from the
internet though i think we'd be able to
get that i take your point about dancing
around certain topics and not saying
certain phrases or certain words in
order to stay on but the fact that
social media that these corporate kind
of faceless corporations
are preventing people from talking i
think is despicable and when he was
cancelled from
twitter
i mean i just think that was a bit of a
game changer when everyone realized that
actually these these globalists uh these
sort of technocrats they have way too
much power on what we can hear well so
here's what we try to do i think you
know we can get like 99 of everything we
want to say on the show because we
mostly talk about current events so
we're talking about like up to date news
that's one of the reasons we don't get
hit a lot when people have candid
conversations on a wide range of topics
that span several years is where youtube
gets you we pull up news articles from
this week it's like hard for them to
enforce what's on newsweek or the new
york times or cnn
but for the greater conversations that
we think you know let's not get banned
we go to timcast.com member segments if
you become a member there and support us
then it allows us to have this more you
know open
granted i'll tell you this we we've had
the corporations like big powerful
players mad at us really mad at us over
our members only segments so i hope
people realize that i really probably
like the one we're about to have yeah oh
it's gonna i imagine this one's gonna
trigger a bunch of
corporate entities but uh people need to
understand that too because when we say
like we're gonna do things at
timcast.com where we we we mostly get to
say whatever we want to say on this show
because we're talking about current
events if there's something where we
think it's gonna cross that line where
youtube would take advantage of it to
ban us
they still know we're doing it and these
these big corporate entities still know
we're doing it they're trying to figure
out how to punish us for our own website
and that's a challenge we're working
towards
i don't want to say too much because we
have we're signing out with some new
companies that are
really going to solidify and fortify our
ability to have conversations of
whatever we want
but
look man
it ain't easy you know i tell people do
you want to sacrifice 99 conversations
for that one i certainly understand not
wanting to give up that one conversation
and if there was something so insanely
important you'd risk getting banned for
it i say we have to have it if there's
something that's not you know
apocalyptic and you know whatever we'll
do a members only speak easy speak easy
kind of show where we'll go in the back
room and get away from the prying eyes
of the establishment but uh you know
there are certain things that i'm like
let's let's go for like the epstein
stuff luke was like how do we deal with
this because we're talking about suicide
we're talking about i'm like no we're
going like no way dude something like
that has to be we'll talk about epstein
all day all week so anyway my friends go
to timkes.com become a member we're
gonna have that members only segment
coming up it'll be published around 11
or so p.m you can follow the show at tim
cast irl you can follow me at tim cast
kelly do you want to shout anything out
you have social media or anything i do
if you want to purchase uh and support
what we do there's a u.s store which is
adult human female.us uh if you're in
the uk or europe and or you don't mind
high postage costs it's uh adulthood
store and you can also support what we
do at standingforwomen.com
oh and kelly j king on youtube right on
let me watch anything else sure uh libby
evans i'm at libby evans on twitter i'm
at the post-millennial every day and if
you want to help us out we get targeted
by antifa all the time if you want to
help us out thepostmillennial.com
contribute and you can subscribe to our
newsletters and to our site and uh yeah
all right yeah oh also kelly jay gave me
this pin what is it and it says um it
says mother is a female parent
oh that's nice is that the actual
definition of the word very happy about
it it's abbreviated to get on a pin yeah
i mean it is you know so that's what
we're going to talk about the membership
shorter than twitter we're going to talk
about definitions dictionary definitions
good my favorite topic
[Laughter]
liturgy hey i'm ian crossland follow me
in crosstalk.now i'll see you guys later
yeah i'm very excited for this
conversation we'll be discussing the
definition of woman which is an adult
human female i'm told i'm stoked i get
to wear my shirt tonight you guys may
follow me on twitter and mines.com at
sour patch lids we will see you all at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you